foreign
[Laughter]
spooky Jenny trying running over me
that's kind of my brand you know what I
mean so I can't help but like whatever
if I do it it's gonna end up spooky
whether I wanted to or not so you know
that's just how that happens looks like
everybody's here they're all starting to
Pile in right now Danny Rowling said
since David Warner just passed away yeah
I think we did it uh mention that but
yeah he just uh died recently yeah you
guys should totally review the 1987
Hansel and Gretel with David Warner by
Canon just a suggestion okay that's that
you know what I don't even know if I've
ever seen that it sounds kind of
familiar though Dave Warner was in like
a million zillion movies but I always
were remembering what's up Dave hey yeah
whatever always going to mannequins
later probably is uh the Island the
island and Tron
and time after time where he played Jack
the Ripper yeah that was my favorite
yeah yeah it was good
Thomas already told me he was at the he
was at the biker bar earlier yeah
midnight at the away yeah I had three
drinks and then they bought me two more
uh-oh so he already said when he got
back because he only just got back at
like 5 30 and he said he's gonna be a
handful yeah and I was like yeah what
else is new yeah I was [ __ ] talking
to a [ __ ] dude uh from the 101st he's
a little bit older than me he was a
black dude from [ __ ] 101st and he
bought me [ __ ] a free chocolate salty
balls he says I want you to put my
chocolate sauce balls in your mouth said
I said okay go ahead
if you guys never had chocolate
chocolate salty balls it's a good shot
real good it's got a salt ring around it
and it's it's kind of like a chocolatey
caramel
I don't know what it is in there uh you
probably don't want to know
let me have let me use my imagination
okay it's kind of like kind of like some
kind of cookie flavor actually it's like
an oatmeal cookie shot I like oatmeal
cookie shot which is probably one of my
favorite shots ever yeah that's like
probably that's probably the girliest
thing I've ever said but oh no cookie
shots are delicious
almost as good as lemon drops or I don't
know I think maybe lemon maybe oatmeal
cookie shots David Parker's in the house
what's up Dave yeah I already said that
okay then he's going to mannequins
probably okay although I think maybe not
I don't know we were thinking about
going to Barbarella tomorrow night yeah
we'll see but we'll see how it goes I'm
kind of broke dick yeah I got money I
got credit
[Laughter]
we had big expenses this month had to
buy that [ __ ] three thousand dollar
[ __ ] lawnmower well at least we have
to pay for it all at once I mean
you know
and you did go out there now did you
utilize here's the big question because
why why is that funny uh you can see
remember in Idiocracy utilize Matt [ __ ]
yeah yeah the dude from our dimension
for our time would say utilize a lot and
they'd start laughing oh utilize yeah
utilize
well wasn't it like wasn't it a running
gag that like pretty much every word
meant [ __ ] in that kind of yeah that's
what I'm saying half of the word and
they all were like Beavis and
butt-headed about it yeah yeah utilized
yeah
yeah so now now that you've like went
off on your Beavis and Butthead brand I
totally forgot what I'm talking about it
no I was gonna no I was gonna say that
um you know when did you use the cup
holder yeah oh no on there no [ __ ] no I
was serious that first time
I got on there man I put my hat on and
everything [ __ ] put my hat on [ __ ]
I even took my shirt off halfway through
it to get some sun to let everybody know
I was [ __ ] serious about mowing
let's look at yeah cause I watch how
these other dudes are out here do it
they get serious about it too but
people were waving at me while I was
working that's right you know the dudes
are saying yeah that's right it's a
whole little like weird culture it's a
it's it's a Suburban scent well it's not
really suburb a semi-rural culture about
who's mowing your who's lawn
and are you mowing your own lawn with
your own mower are you hiring dudes to
come in and I'm mowing my own so I'm now
in a club so dudes [ __ ] trying buying
their [ __ ] their waving and saluting
and [ __ ] [ __ ] that's right okay yeah
next time I will have a damn
drink have it have a cocktail yeah but
you see the thing is I'm thinking it's a
bad idea
because half the time I was in a dust
cloud
well yeah or in a cloud of [ __ ]
you'll be drinking yeah Airborne dirt
Airborne dirt and and Airborne good for
it's good for your immune system yeah
Airborne grass clippings because grass
clippings give it a little bit of flavor
yeah now if I stay on top of it and
don't let it grow and just run you know
what I mean and just keep it low that
might be
the way you know it might be the way to
do it uh we'll see I'm gonna I'm gonna
make you a t-shirt that has a riding
lawnmower with a little cartoon you
sitting on it like holding up a cocktail
and then it'll be like Tom's serious
mowing Club yeah
like around me yeah
just riding it around and fantasizing
about the YouTube videos that I saw of
the dude going down the ramp and ramping
and ramping over his pool this is gonna
end badly well his friends are watching
this is gonna end badly he doesn't make
the jump it's kind of like Evil Knievel
not making the Snake Canyon river drop
I'm just saying right now you drink some
cocktails out on that [ __ ] and then you
go into that into that like kind of
ditch over there in the corner and the
[ __ ] falls on you and you're out there
pinned and you're like waving your
little arms around and stuff don't be
calling me for help because I told you
I'm like that dude I'm like that dude
out of here I'm like that dude out of
[ __ ] uh I shouldn't be alive that's
what I was just thinking of his
four-wheeler he wasn't drunk though he
was actually in in the shitty thing
about that was that not only was he
penned under the four-wheeler but he
lived was he lived like in this real
remote like in [ __ ] Alaska or some
[ __ ] or Canada or something like that
and he had lived up there for a long
time so he was like you know lived off
the land
and he was going out to like check on
some [ __ ] and it just so happened that
he hit like a stick or some [ __ ] like
that and the and the four-wheeler tipped
over and fell on him yeah he couldn't
get up underneath and crushed his legs
it was a four liter four-wheeler loaded
with a bunch of stuff yeah because he
was going out like on a hunting trip or
something and he wasn't a strong guy he
was a little spindly guy he just
couldn't get it off him
yeah well I mean he was pinned for
[ __ ] almost a week underneath that
damn thing yeah it was like yeah and he
couldn't get to like any water or food
and then there was Wolves yeah wolves
trying to eat trying to eat his face off
and it was a bad situation but he did
get he did get through it they
eventually found him so we found him
yeah somebody found him I mean like he's
lucky that they did because nobody came
there like they even said like and he
was with inside of a house
remember that he could see a house he
could hear [ __ ] dogs barking and hear
people yes so he kept like yelling but
they tried to yell he was trying to
flash him when he had some kind of
flashlight I think are you trying to
flash yeah he had a few things that he
could read he could reach it yeah but
because it was all loaded up too late
yeah but I mean well he I mean he
obviously he lived otherwise he wouldn't
be on that show because he lost his leg
though
yeah I think he didn't yes because it
was well it was completely crushed and
it was and it was completely crushed for
several days so it had gone like
completely
agreed he didn't have any circulation in
it which is why y'all [ __ ] need to
work out be as strong as you can
I don't know if I could have gotten out
underneath it but I probably could have
it was 400 something pounds like no it
was way heavier though it was 400 pounds
no it was more like a couple thousand
pounds was it that much yeah it was like
super super heavy I didn't think it was
that heavy yeah it was like real heavy
like it was so heavy because I remember
that I don't remember exactly how much
it weighed but I remember them like
saying how much it weighed and I'm just
like yeah I don't think anybody like
even some big muscle man could have
pulled it pushed it off him
um I would have cut my own [ __ ] leg
off to try to get money some people have
done that too yeah well then that one
guy that was like he was mountain
climbing I think and then he found like
an art like a [ __ ] rock fell on his
arm
and he eventually like cut his own arm
off I'm like that's uh that's hardcore
yeah yeah uh murder Horner return says
forgot the old country singer in
Nashville but he got a DUI on his
lawnmower yeah was he on the road I
imagine he was probably out of the road
oh I got murder hornet in there yeah
okay
all right
um I was gonna tell something you sure
the shirts came in just waiting on the
die
yeah that's yeah the blank shirts came
today but the dies not coming until
Tuesday yeah so Tuesday with the dial
because it's in [ __ ] Wisconsin so I
won't be able to probably mail it out
minimum Wednesday because yeah and then
the next day they got a [ __ ] female
yeah I got to do the postage and all
that
uh next Dimension media hey Jenny and
Tom just finished watching your hardcore
review that was a lot of fun to do I
really like that movie don't know if
it's true or not but I heard Richard
Pryor pulled a gun on pulse reader when
he was directing blue collar I had not
heard that but it surprised me I mean
the thing about Pryor was [ __ ] cool
hell yeah he'd pull a gun on somebody
yeah well I don't know how cool that is
that's very cool it's very cool it
depends on because if Pryor pulled a gun
out on you [ __ ] you deserved it or
you said something about his mom
something like that yeah
Danny Rollings is talking about uh wax
work is a good David Warner film yeah I
like that one as well I've seen that one
a couple times actually right actually
I'm amazed that we haven't
uh covered that one yeah some of the
coolest [ __ ] on this planet
have pulled guns out on on people
including Elvis
they're trying to take that damn [ __ ]
those drugs from him but he pulled that
[ __ ] cut out on his friends
he also shot a TV shooting the
television whenever they talk [ __ ] about
him on TV he'd read children grab his
[ __ ] 19 11 45 [ __ ] black I'm like
you're not you're not shooting the
actual person right just the TV it's
just very Southern and very Macho and it
is I'll get a new TV bring a new TV in
here well that's what I mean Elvis could
afford it he could afford TVs yeah
[Laughter]
Zach said
uh I don't think I've seen a director
with such an up and down career as Paul
Schrader some of his films are
masterpieces and others are total crap
yeah I always kind of wonder about that
you know I did there I don't know it
seems like there's
I don't know there are some directors
that seem like all of their shit's
really good and then some directors that
all their stuff really sucks but then
there's some that are like some of their
shits like super super brilliant and the
rest of it is just like terrible and I'm
not really sure like why that is yeah
not really sure why that is
uh wax work the sequel is good too I
don't know if I've ever seen the sequel
I've seen the first one like two or
three times probably but wait is that
the same no that was House of Wax that
had Paris was it was Paris Hilton what
the [ __ ] is that chick's name then Paris
Hilton get killed in that which one in
the House of Wax remake oh I didn't see
the acid we Remax the house of Remax
I didn't see the House of Wax remake
didn't see it I think I remember just
watching it because I was like oh I
heard Paris Hilton gets killed in a
horrible horrible way though she was
cute for a flash flash as a chick she's
all right
you're pretty cute for a flat test
[Laughter]
that's how that's how I'm rolling
rolling yeah okay that's like you are
gonna you are gonna be a handful I can
tell because you haven't you haven't
even started like drinking well I mean
you haven't started drinking out here
out here right you've been drinking and
then and then but because he came in
yeah with his big you know [ __ ]
ridiculous jethrojar he comes in with
that
and then he's like oh I made this like
way too strong and then he's like I
already had like a bunch of drinks at
the Oasis I have I had four yeah well I
like it that's not that many I mean
comparatively yeah in a shot but
yeah maybe two shots we'll see but you
were there for several hours so it's not
like you just got there and like pounded
the [ __ ] down it was like over several
hours no Paris Hilton was cute she was
just uh skinny
skinny and fat
just gotta say yeah just getting flat
Danny Rowling said Paris Hilton died
giving head in House of waxes to a steel
pole
[Laughter]
just remember her having like a really
uh yeah a steel pole at the back of her
head that's right I remember having kind
of a memorable death
but you know so there's that look at you
he could get all looking all offensive
yeah I was just sitting there thinking
about
parasail
like I hadn't seen her in a while she's
probably she you know she'd be a lot
older now uh well yeah everyone yeah I
wonder how she wonder what she looks
like now um
maybe she put some put some weight on
her I I literally had not thought of her
until I thought of wax work and then I
thought of House of Wax right and then I
thought of her being in their house at
wax remake that's why I thought of her
but other than that I haven't thought of
her for years if you don't live here in
the U.S you'd know that she isn't a
thing anymore she was a thing back then
but she's not she's not thinking you
don't have any [ __ ] seen her
murder when I return says was an Octomom
in a low budget horror yes she's also in
a porn flick it was called
what was it called I saw it like I
didn't see it on purpose like because
octomon was in it I just happened to
because what I used to do sometimes when
Hulu was free like when it had free
content they had like a whole bunch of
like shitty like B horror movies so
sometimes when I was bored like on
weekends I would just like put on horror
movies at random and that was one of the
ones that I saw what the [ __ ] was it
called delivery like Devil's Child or
something like that it was like a Satan
baby thing yeah and it was
awful yeah it was awful Octomom was just
a [ __ ] another thing you know just
it was back when there was a [ __ ]
mass media every time they say Octomom I
always think of like a woman with
tentacles yeah that's probably just me
but she did it she did a porn scene did
she have tentacles in that was it hentai
how funny would that have been I don't
know if octo mom would have done
something she did a porn scene too but
she didn't really do much in it from
what I remember it's been a long time
since I've seen it she was cute but
like big [ __ ] deal yeah
I don't remember what she looked like I
do remember seeing and seeing her in
that movie and thinking I didn't even
realize it was Octomom until later
because I don't really follow that kind
of stuff like when I was because I was
writing something about it later and I
was just kind of like oh that's that
chick yeah I kind of vaguely remember
that I was like wow she was like
annoying as [ __ ] in that movie so I
wonder if she's like that in real life
the Octomom porn movie was definitely a
rip-off it was just they were just
trying to try to sell you something
because you know because you were
curious she doesn't really do much
anything I mean
had it been me directing this [ __ ] she'd
been doing stunts and like yeah eight
come out eight are going in I would have
[ __ ] said some kind of [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] like that and like uh made some
stunts to see what would you know
insertion starts
measuring her up see how big she is that
type of [ __ ] it would have been cooler
if you'd have gone like surrealist with
it where you could have just had like a
big huge vagina with like some like yeah
I don't know circus dwarves like just
[ __ ] or something yeah dude's running
out of it I wrote a story a long time
ago where somebody like in virtual
reality but they actually like drove
their car inside a giant vagina yeah so
there was that yeah but and one of the
books that I reviewed recently womb
which is actually like really good if
you're if you're not like squeamish
about body horror like extreme horror
it's actually really good
um that one like a dude uh he wants to
insert his entire head into a woman's
vagina and he does
actually there was a there was an old
demonetized yeah well you said oh well
there there was a it's just a body part
there there was uh back in back in the
old internet Gore Gallery they had all
kinds of [ __ ] crazy ass photographs
from [ __ ] crime scenes the serial
killing they had Jeffrey Dahmer
photographs the [ __ ] the photographs
he took I remember that and one of them
was a photograph of a dude with his head
inside of a woman like that
but you read the comments people thought
it might have been fake you know I mean
it was early Photoshop days there's no
way of knowing if it was real well I
mean if I saw I'm not gonna go looking
for it but if I saw it I could probably
tell she was a big woman but I don't
think you could put your head in a woman
like that
well even in the context of the story
like the the book that I read
um you know that which was fiction
obviously but even before that like
throughout the course of it because it's
like a frame story they were telling
stories back and forth like they got
grosser and grosser as it went along but
um he like the whole time was like
stretching her out yeah you know what I
mean and she was actually kind of known
she was a sex worker and she was kind of
known for having like a cavernous you
wrote this [ __ ] no I read that okay the
one I wrote was like I said was like
about a virtual reality thing where a
guy would like fantasize about driving
into someone's vagina there was a
[ __ ] joke I remember from a kid
is where dude's going down on some chick
and [ __ ] he spits it out like that
it's a set of keys and [ __ ] he's like
what the [ __ ] is that you know what I
mean there's those I've been looking for
those
you know what I mean [ __ ] another
dude [ __ ] goes oh great [ __ ] it I
haven't been able to get this car out of
here forever and he runs in there to go
get the car
looking for those
he drives his car out that's [ __ ]
awesome
ridiculous I don't remember exactly how
the [ __ ] I I didn't tell the the joke
right yeah obviously it didn't make any
sense at all that was like when I was
[ __ ] 13 or 14.
yeah finds the keys and another [ __ ]
another dude goes oh that's to my car
they [ __ ] jumps in there and drives
the car out
I remember how well you know it's a
vagina that's why they call it Nature's
garage
they don't I just made that up
[Laughter]
I'm gonna call him from now on though
well I used to I always used to call it
Nature's purse it is Nature's purse yeah
because you can you know put all kinds
of things in there if you need to but
you don't have to say it
where are those contact lenses oh yeah
that's right I put them in nature I put
him in nature's first Zach says Uh
there's a new movie about Marilyn Monroe
coming out
starring Anna De armas of all people but
it actually looks amazing and really
surreal and I just said it on atarmus is
like awesome so she is the one that was
she is she was um she was in uh Blade
Runner in 2049 oh okay yeah and she was
in knives out too yeah yeah yeah yeah
she was in [ __ ] um yeah she was in
one of those James Bond movies yeah yeah
she's cute
she's gonna play Marilyn Monroe I guess
Marilyn Monroe wasn't that cute
well you know they always make you cuter
when they have the movie the same thing
that happens on a haunting man you see
like the real people right and then it's
like oh they have like some hot like
some hot actress yeah or considerably
better looking Monroe was cute in the
context of her time uh you know it was
it was a different scene back then
Hollywood and
I don't know standards I guess were
different I don't know it depends on who
who was [ __ ] who but uh I never
really saw much and I just seen pictures
of old Marilyn Monroe and she's just
there's just nothing to her really not
about today's standards she said she's
okay but she's not
mind-blowing you know well the thing
about Marilyn Monroe that I that I think
people liked so it's not so much just
like still pictures of her but like when
she was in movies like moving around
yeah and because sometimes that's goes a
long way towards yeah like sometimes
when you just see like yeah I guess it's
a cultural you have to have the cultural
context because that's even her just
moving around like there's not much to
her
you know just just a woman you know good
looking woman but
[ __ ] Tom is not impressed no [ __ ] no
women got really good looking in the
[ __ ] 60s and 70s
you know that was like fake eyelashes
and all that kind of stuff came along
I don't care I don't care looks super
good
uh you know I can um
[ __ ]
Elizabeth Montgomery was [ __ ] badass
[ __ ] um
bunch of them were you know they just
they were good looking women just I
don't want to see the retama does it
it's just on television that you
remember uh what was her name Barbie
Benton she was [ __ ] good looking
um yeah well back then they didn't
really they didn't put other guys on TV
no you know what I mean well they still
don't until like to relax yeah but you
know what I mean
um
girl who played [ __ ] I Dream of
Jeannie from [ __ ] I Dream of Jeannie
what was her name again [ __ ] um
what was her name I can't remember
you guys remember what I'm talking about
Zach uh is telling the joke guy goes in
a vagina guy dad is that you is that
where you disappeared to when I was a
kid and then murder her in turn says
first guy used a ladder and found
another guy in there and lost his ladder
the other guy said if you help me find
my keys we can drive out yeah yeah
[Laughter]
yeah Barbara Eden was probably one of
the best looking women of all times she
was looking great yeah uh what do we
think of the new Monsters trailer I'm
not sure how to feel about it like
it looks cheesy as [ __ ]
but then again the original show was
kind of cheesy as [ __ ] and that's what a
lot of people like about it
so in a way I'm kind of like ambivalent
because I'm like well since it was Rob
Zombie I like expected him to like ooh
I'm gonna like Edge it up or somebody
but he's like a huge monsters fan so
maybe he wanted to capture more of the
original Spirit of the show which is
cool but I'm not really sure how that's
going to translate I don't know I'm kind
of like interested to see it because I
was like watching it and I'm just like I
don't know I can't tell if this is gonna
be the best thing ever or the most awful
thing ever I couldn't tell
uh Andy River Rockefeller said are you
guys doing a review on the new Elvis
movie very curious to hear your thoughts
I loved it yeah
um it might still be playing uh if it's
if it's not then we will probably have
to wait for it for streaming we still
pay for that stupid [ __ ] movie
theater thing it's like why don't we
ever go
we never have seem to have time you're
always working and I mean I got lots of
movies that I wanted to see has anybody
seen nope because I kind of wanted to
see that evidently wasn't any good
I don't know I've heard well I didn't I
didn't really want to like watch any
reviews so you know what I mean because
it looked cool it it eventually bombed
well that doesn't mean it wasn't good
okay you know what I mean a lot of
movies bombed that are still good
um most movies I think are bombing right
now but uh and we didn't get to see uh
[ __ ] Top Gun too either yeah I
thought you were like all Jazz yeah we
don't ever get around to going anywhere
you know she blames me but she's the
ones working all the time
I'm not working on Thursdays or
Saturdays though we're working all the
time like usually I have time to do that
because I've told you before we could
like this one
um
in the theaters far now
well yeah that's another thing you know
it's far now might have to kill that one
but you only have to go once or twice a
week and it make and it makes it worth
it once or twice a month once or twice a
month I mean yeah and it makes it worth
it yeah because it's only like 20
something dollars for a whole month and
you can see three movies I mean
technically you can see three movies a
week if you want to yeah and most people
evidently most people don't
yeah but like you said you only see like
two or three movies a month yeah and
that and it pays for itself because you
know one ticket well if you go to like
the Dolby Theater like one ticket is
like what 14 some [ __ ] like yeah so you
paid for it is it twelve dollars
fourteen dollars something it's
expensive and you also get perks like
you get free popcorn and [ __ ] on your
birthday and every time you go you get
points and then you get Five Dollar
coupons so a lot of times you get like
you can get candy for free you can get
drinks for like you know 50 cents or
something like that she's talking about
AMC Stubs
well it's AMC Stubs A-list A-list yeah
you're an a-lister you pay every month
and then you
just go watching watch three movies a
week I mean if I was living right next
to a theater and and you know I would
which we kind of used to but if I was
right next to a theater in AMC I'd
[ __ ] definitely get that you go down
there and see movies as they come out
and I'd only see the Dolby ones
the [ __ ] Dolby Theater is badass yeah
it's just that a lot of them a lot of
them are Chuck I mean when we first got
that app
we went down there religiously three
times a week and you could burn out on
movies well because we were doing a show
we were doing a show so a lot of times
we were seeing movies that we wouldn't
have gone to see otherwise yeah some of
them things are bad
they end up being real samey and kind of
like okay
and then ones that you wouldn't think
you would like turned out to be the
better ones like a lot of the animated
ones were were better
than live action
um some of the stuff that was damn near
documentaries were good
like that one about the [ __ ] pray the
gay away religious movie that's looking
pretty good I likes that too yeah
and then um
the one about the [ __ ] old the old
white dude living in the [ __ ] house
and the [ __ ] black couple [ __ ]
moves and he tries to steal a [ __ ]
woman that [ __ ] [ __ ] it was like a
lifetime movie but I still liked it that
was like that was like camping and
cheesy as [ __ ] yeah but I was like I was
like super into it yeah it was a good
time it was a good time like you said it
was exactly like it was pretty much
exactly like a lifetime movie but just
like with a slightly higher budget but
that was kind of what I liked about it
I'm like oh my God this is cheesy as
[ __ ] and I'm here for it yeah
dude pop out and [ __ ] look at the
black girl with his yeah with his weight
yeah
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] was the name of that thing
I forgot it had like a generic it was
just what was it called the Intruder or
the Intruder I think or something like
that or what it was called yeah it had
like what the [ __ ] was the name of the
Dead dude that did it God damn it um I
can't remember anybody's name today yeah
I'm getting mad cow
like Alzheimer's and I forgot the name
of that dude who played the creepy old
white dude that's what I was just trying
to remember God damn it what the [ __ ]
he's like he's famous he's famous yeah
Dennis Quaid Dennis Quaid anyway Dennis
Quaid was [ __ ] chewing up a scenery
he had like his his smile was like you
know you know and How the Grinch Stole
Christmas like the original like Boris
Karloff cartoon where his little smile
goes real like that it was like that and
I was just kind of like that is that's
awesome and
I think the movie was mostly made for a
black audience I think [ __ ] your head
a black couple with [ __ ] hot [ __ ]
black chick as the wife and this [ __ ]
creepy old white dude imma steal your
woman who wouldn't leave you just
wouldn't [ __ ] leave he's going after
this [ __ ] well it was there he they
bought the house from him like it was it
and at first they were just Wesley's
house yeah yeah it was his house but
like he sold it to them and then like
yeah he was living oh I just thought I'd
be nice and come here and mow your lawn
and they're like great that's nice will
you please go away we actually lived in
an underground bunker Yeah the secret
passages up into the house and he was
lusting over the damn wife yeah it was
[ __ ] weird as [ __ ] but I liked it I
did too I like that it was entertaining
I was laughing through the whole thing
which I'm sure it was like kind of
supposed to be scary but it was actually
like hilarious like it was yeah it
wasn't scary to me I just no I didn't
think it was I just thought I thought I
mean if you were obviously if you were
in a situation like that a real life
would be scary but it's like in the
movie not so much yeah this is the way
it was portrayed
the dude's trying to get rid of this
[ __ ] Dennis Quaid old white dude dude
I mean try to get rid he's trying to be
polite to him at the same time they're a
professional couple he's like wait hey
man you know [ __ ] uh you sold the
house to us you don't have to come mow
the lawn and he said no no it's okay
it's okay and he just can't get rid of
this dude yeah little does he know the
dude's living underneath the [ __ ]
ground yeah lusting over his wife and I
forgot who the [ __ ] actress was that
played the wife but
yeah she was in some other movies yeah
she had [ __ ] really nice legs and
they can't [ __ ] showing her and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and [ __ ] in quads looking and
licking his [ __ ] lips and [ __ ]
why did you just you just did a thing
like Hannibal Lecter yeah
I'm like ew and he was giving him SOB
stories about it and he was like old
enough to be her Grandpa yeah probably
Dennis Quaid was pretty old he's in his
60s I think or at least her dad yeah she
was probably uh 30s mid-30s man yeah
Brody yeah
look at old dudes yeah it was awesome
he's trying to protect his wife and [ __ ]
from this old dude
yeah but it never really comes to blows
until the very end he can't prove
anything because the guy's [ __ ] we'll
see that's the [ __ ] of like all that
was what the whole movie was that's kind
of like yeah it's well it's just kind of
like that's what a lot of those Lifetime
movies are like too because a lot of
times that's what's scary about it
because if you could just like call the
cops and the cops come and take the
person away then the movie's over yeah
so it's like they always have to be like
some Super Genius that knows exactly
like the letter of the law so they can
like skirt around everything so there's
like never anything that you can do
about it anything yeah and it's like
well I can't shoot him in the face
because then I'll get in trouble and you
know what I mean so it's just like this
whole thing
so you know what I mean that's it's
drama that's the conflict but yeah that
was that was like a very funny yeah it
was very funny but um I'm gonna find out
what movie that was I think it was
called Intruder or the intruder
am I crazy is that what it was called I
remember it having like kind of a
generic name but yeah I think it was but
Dennis Quaid yeah
and it was just it was two years ago
maybe 2019. I want to say yeah I thought
it was 2019 maybe 2018. I can't really
remember
and yeah they're talking about the
Intruder yeah so I got it I'm not as
stupid as I thought all right cast on
the intruder
Dennis Quaid Michael early Megan Good
was her name Megan Good
yes
okay wasn't the guy that was in it
wasn't he in the Jacob's Ladder reboot I
want to say uh maybe I wish I didn't
love
I mean it's kind of hard to top the
original Jacob's Ladder gonna say but
they did reboot it I didn't even know
they rebooted it like did a remake and
then I was just like it was free one day
so I was like ah what the [ __ ] can I
watch it and I was like
it was all right it wasn't terrible
nothing to write home about you know
yeah they're talking about the monsters
thing
I don't know I mean
I don't know if I want to pay to watch
it but yeah that was it yeah that's
right
yeah
let's see if he does the [ __ ] he does
the [ __ ] Facebook yeah where he's
licking his lips and [ __ ] like Hannibal
Lecter then he could yeah here I am I
mean he's still looking pretty good in
that even though yeah he's old as [ __ ]
and obviously old enough to be her dad
yeah big time but
that's that's the house and he was
living underneath underneath the ground
and he had no intention of leaving
and uh yeah so he starts seeing all this
[ __ ] going down he gets fat he gets
[ __ ] infatuated with the wife
he's mowing the lawn and [ __ ] he won't
go anywhere
hell yeah I thought that was a [ __ ]
great movie and it was just a low budget
[ __ ] movie that I remembered after
all this time it was at least memorable
well yeah because it went like so over
the top like so it almost can't be yeah
like it went campy but like I said if
you're gonna do that at least make it
yeah stand out and and I thought the
acting was good I thought the movie was
kind of punching up but most people were
like ah it's just the same old [ __ ] but
I liked it I liked it I don't give a
[ __ ] what they said no I was gonna say
if Dennis Quaid wasn't in it it might
not have been quite as good no it might
it would have just been like you know
like good but just like all the other
ones yeah he made that but he just like
went way over the top yeah yeah I mean
yeah really cute
Danny Rowling said that sounds a lot
like the 1989 Gary Busey film Hider in
the house that's right I've heard of
that yeah man can you imagine how what
if we have Gary Busey in our house right
now yeah [ __ ] hide
with this big [ __ ] horse he's beating
down on you you're having sex and he's
over there watching beats Jerry Who's
his [ __ ] mouth and [ __ ]
like you heard something and then like
you're going down the hall to the
bathroom or something like that and you
see these big white teeth glowing in the
darkness then he's over there standing
at the corner
speaking of which do you know what woke
me up this morning I mean it's always
something
because I can't just [ __ ] sleep
because my stupid body won't let me
sleep I woke up at four o'clock this
morning because I heard this frantic
really really loud scratching
and the first thing I thought was that I
bet Pookie got locked in one of the
closets because she likes to go in the
bedroom clothes we try not to let her go
in there because she'll like tear up
Tom's Shoes
but a lot of times she'll kind of Stand
by the door and be like please please
please please let me go in there and
then like sometimes if you forget like
she'll go in there and then she'll curl
up way in the back corner and then
she'll fall asleep and then you close
the door because you forget she's in
there so I thought that that's what it
was Zach sent that too yeah I know that
is that is Marilyn Monroe yeah and I
really just don't think there's anything
to her
it's just she's not ugly she's just a
you know average girl
but yeah so so anyway so I hear all this
uh scratching and it was like really
really loud it woke me up at like four
o'clock in the morning and I thought
Pokey was like stuck in a closet
somewhere and I came out I was like what
the [ __ ] is that noise oh my God and
then I looked downstairs because like
you come out the bedroom and like you
can look down the you know down the
staircase like into where the front door
is and she comes tear-assing out of the
laundry room where the litter box is and
then just come tearing up the stairs
she was in that [ __ ] litter box going
like so loud that it was waking me up
from like all the way downstairs and I
was like I was like pookie I thought you
were
thought you were trapped in a closet you
were making so much noise but she was
just in the damn litter box making as
much noise as possible lion Warrior says
that uh if you got Gary Busey in your
house make sure you got plenty of
Columbia product yeah probably right
yeah
Gary bus if you snorting your [ __ ]
snorting your house that he's starting
to snorting the whole house up maybe
that's what you'd find him doing like in
the middle of the night he'd just be
like down on the carpet just like
sucking up all the cat hair and whatever
Danny Rollings it and the Steven Weber
2013 film crawl space aka the remake of
Hyder in the house
well that's not a that's not a remake of
crawl space the one with Klaus Kinski
why are there so many movies called
crawl space
Steven Weber was the same guy that was
in the TV version of The Shining wasn't
he yeah because he was on wings
they've made so many movies about uh a
guy secretly lives in your house y'all
yeah I mean I guess because that would
be pretty scary because if you've seen
like those videos where
um you know people like somebody like
live in a cabinet and then like when you
went to work they'd climb out and like
eat your [ __ ] out of your fridge that
was actually happening well that's what
I'm saying yeah so it does happen we got
to do a show about that
people wait actually maybe we shouldn't
that would be I mean some of those like
some of those videos might be fake but I
think it has actually happened like
several times they had one where some
little black woman was living in
somebody's [ __ ] closet up on the top
and coming out
and eating their [ __ ]
[ __ ] while they were at work and then
she'd go back up in there and live she'd
and then she did it for like over a year
can you imagine yeah
be a trip we should go probably go check
the item you go check the Attic
I mean because
well I mean something like that happened
in Japan too that's yeah that's the one
I was thinking of right I just thought I
wrote down people who live in other
people's cabinets yeah I'll know what I
mean
okay people so I'm gonna show this off I
got a Canon Studios
design right here that is the original
Canon logo the Jenny [ __ ] stole from
the internet and I got that thing on a
damn
screen and I can make any kind of shirt
you want any size
sleeveless or with sleeves
for a 20 Super Chat
I will send you one of these Cannon
shirts and we'll work we'll get your
address and if I can send it to you
later probably going to be uh until
Wednesday when's the die coming Tuesday
Thursday so probably be able to send it
out Wednesday just drop a 20 Super Chat
and I'll send you a [ __ ] canister
okay back to the show
gotta do a commercial break
Zach says also I listened to your old
episodes about scientology and now I'm
just addicted to Chris Shelton's podcast
yeah I can't stop listening I blame you
I've talked to Shelton yeah uh Shelton
he's very much in the Box I talked to
him back in the days it's about eight
eight years ago as soon as he left the
cult
I thought about doing a show with him
but he's he's too nerdy what's the
matter of being nerdy well cut no
because no matter what he's still a
Scientologist no matter what and he he
judges you as if you are a Scientologist
he saw all the god stuff and he's like
oh wow he just thought that was another
cult you know
oh he's one of those huh yeah he's one
of those yeah it's just like having a
[ __ ] very much kind of like having a
fundamentalist Christian around
um but he is no thanks yes
uh Sheldon got into that [ __ ] because uh
he was big into Star Wars and he thought
he thought Scientology was a path into
learning the [ __ ] Force
and uh no
no trans was a guy named Prince father's
first name
um he he helped run Scientology he was
like one of the [ __ ] highest ranking
scientologists and he was the only black
Scientologist he's right underneath L
Ron Hubbard when it came to [ __ ]
testing he was one of the chief auditor
kind of like scientology's version of a
grand Inquisitor
he joined Scientology because he had a
[ __ ] spontaneous Out of Body
Experience like I had
uh and he thought that he joined the
cult because he thought Scientology
could teach him how to do that again
through astral projection
but as he got deeper into it he realized
that no it's the exact opposite of what
you need
to learn how to how to astrally project
um they'll astrally project all your
money yeah they actually project that
money out of your damn pocket that's
pretty much all that's what it's about
I'm gonna tell you right although um
Jesse his name is Jesse Prince Jesse
Prince did believe in Scientology for
most of the time that he was in there
he thought that it could discipline you
and get you to do you know get you to
learn certain skills there are some
things in Scientology that might be
useful
but not a lot I don't think it's worth
the worth what they're paying you what
what they're charging you well I mean a
lot of them I mean the the only [ __ ] in
there that's useful is [ __ ] you can
figure out on your own for free so yeah
well they have a lot of pretty much they
call it the tech the spiritual
technology is what they call it and a
lot of that spiritual technology or
spiritual Tech has been squirreled as
they put it in other words bootlegged
it's out there you can get it for free
um now they would go through exercises
and training
but here's the thing that is not
spiritual technology most of that [ __ ]
is what I would call sales technique
very much like Robert L shook's Hardball
tactics
which is how to get people how to
convince people and how to get people to
sign on a dotted line using very subtle
high pressure sales techniques
the Scientology has a lot of that kind
of stuff in it
um where it's it's
powers
of the mind but it's not met it's not
paranormal it's psychological
you know the power to persuade or the
power to force someone with the power to
guilt someone into doing something
that's what a lot of it is
um
but I did have this weird begrudging
respect for Scientology
it was made up out of nothing by a guy
who didn't know a whole hell of a lot
and he turned that [ __ ] into a very
powerful cult that could pull people in
and make a bunch of money and buy a
bunch of property
but but that's basically what it what it
is I don't know I don't find anything
admirable about somebody that just
pulled something out of their butt and
like took advantage of people because of
it
you know
you're just like taking advantage of
people's stupidity and gullibility
that's not cool yeah I'm saying but
that's what it is well yeah I know but I
said that's not cool or admirable I
don't think well I admire it I admire it
in the same way that [ __ ] um that
robot from Alien admired the [ __ ]
xenomorph that it was [ __ ] without
any that's a good analogy
that it is a [ __ ] Superior is this
Superior creature because it's extremely
hostile and it has no delusions of
morality that it just does what it does
you know and and that's that's what
Scientology is it just does what it does
um
it's the kind of like a cockroach
I don't like those either if you're
right you don't like them but the
[ __ ] can survive a nuclear
Holocaust and I don't admire them
Scientology could probably survive a
nuclear Holocaust because they're
[ __ ] very insular they have secret
bases they even have a [ __ ] secret
base out in the desert with a bunch of
[ __ ]
underground and underground Silo holding
all the [ __ ] El rods Hubbard's
[ __ ] teachings on what was it
titanium plates inside of [ __ ] some
[ __ ] like that hermetically sealed
plastic containers deep under the Earth
in the desert
like all the money and expense and time
that went into that useless yeah
evidently the guy's guarding it have
[ __ ] a pretty high suicide rate too
you know I I get it you might as well
just be in a Maximum Security Prison
because that's what it is it's a Maximum
Security Prison out in the middle of the
desert and you don't even have anybody
to talk to no it's just some dudes
guarding this [ __ ] underneath the ground
in these vaults it's [ __ ] bizarre
creepy creepy it is very creepy yeah
Danny Rowling said there's a new TV show
called Hider in my house about different
cases of unknown people living in your
home damn now see eyes and now we gotta
know more about that well [ __ ] I'm gonna
have to go yeah wrote it down over here
because that I'm fascinated by that well
like I said
dude I mean they're like this house
isn't that big but it's just kind of
like I could see
I could see somebody living in here I
may not know about it
although I will say that um they
wouldn't be able well I don't they
wouldn't be able to like come out
obviously because you know we're here
all the time because you know I work at
home and Tom is retired so
it's not like we'd leave and they could
come out and like use the shower and
whatever I'd be like hey who the [ __ ]
using my shower you know what I mean so
so I don't really think they could
to be living in the closet or like you
know living in the Attic or something I
would hear him like immediately what you
were saying before about Chris Shelton
and about how he didn't like the The
Goth thing I was watching
um there's this channel I watch is this
goth girl who and I think I mentioned
her before what's God damn it what is
her name it's and I think it's Angela
something but um she does like a lot of
videos about God she's a little bit
younger than us but I think not that
much I think she's was born in 78 or 79
or something like that
um but so she's kind of like more she
came of age like during the 90s goth and
she was doing a a little video about
how Goths and alternative kids were
perceived in the late 80s and early 90s
because she was a teenager around that
time
and she showed like a bunch of clips
from those terrible like TV uh you know
the TV talk shows like [ __ ] Sally
Jesse Raphael and Jenny Jones and all
that kind of stuff and I had forgotten
like [ __ ] how horrifying
those bucket shows were like they'd have
like some little girl coming out and
she's like 14 or some [ __ ] and she's
like kind of gothy looking she comes out
and like [ __ ] grown ass adults and
the audience are like booing her yeah
yeah and talking about I'm just like
she's 14. [ __ ] the [ __ ] off and it's
like and her mom like allows that to
happen I'm like Oh my God in defense to
the audience that girl probably needed
some like [ __ ] therapy in defense of
the audience though they probably had a
damn [ __ ] sign up there saying boo
well they do they do and I mean the
stupid thing about a running man it was
it was just like it was and it was just
like like watching it now like it was
kind of appalling at the time but like I
haven't seen it in a long time so seeing
clips of it nowadays and I was like
brought back a lot is like oh my God
that was so [ __ ] up and like seeing it
now like with the benefit of hindsight
it's even more horrifying and I was just
like because like I said some of these
kids were like 13 14 years old and you
know they just had like they didn't even
look that weird they just had like by
today's standards they just kind of had
you know some kind of crazy eye shadow
or whatever and like some big hair or
some different color hair and the thing
about it was like even the ones that
were older like some of them asked them
well do you have a job and like some of
them had you know they had normal ass
jobs and they went to school like they
had one girl on there who kind of looked
like a punk rocker she had like a mohawk
and everything and they said well do you
have a job she's like yeah I work at a
daycare and everybody was like everybody
had a [ __ ] fit yeah and she's like I
can put my hair down and like look kind
of normal like when I'm at work duh
uh Danny Danny really Ghostface says
that uh [ __ ] he said I'm gonna have
to watch that Dennis Quaid Intruder film
now because that type of order to me is
really scary yeah yo that was look we
watched movies for [ __ ] years on on
IMC [ __ ] probably two years pretty
much [ __ ] solid until drove is crazy
and that was one of the ones that
actually stood out to me there was other
good movies yeah we saw a bunch of good
ones there was some good most of them
[ __ ] were [ __ ] but that
particular movie was a [ __ ] movie
that stood out I liked it I liked it
because it kind of reminded me of
the movies that would stand out and [ __ ]
in in the 80s of the 90s it kind of
reminded me of [ __ ] you know Fatal
Attraction or yeah it reminded me very
much of those fear Thrillers like you're
like Pacific Heights or like yeah like
those movies that came out like in the
90s like single white female yeah yeah
like stuff like it reminded me of that
like but in a good way yeah like it was
a throwback it's a good movie it's a
good movie and it was and it just came
and went and forgotten well man me and
Jenny remember we should do single white
female yeah on this show one time I love
that movie actually now
um
John Smith says Scientology is so secret
that no one's seen David Miss cabbage's
wife for years her name is [ __ ]
Shelly yeah Shelley Miss cabbage but
they know where she is she's up uh at
rim of the earth I think what's called
up in the uh mountains
of California they got her just doing a
menial tasks a little [ __ ]
Scientology job Xerox and papers and
[ __ ] [ __ ] doing people's [ __ ]
reports or something you know
um
what happened was is that
she is somehow defied him defied [ __ ]
David miscavige over something and they
got she had a thought of her own can't
have that yeah well I think what it is
is based on [ __ ] everything that say
Karen to the carrier and some of the
other ones they said is that she uh
dissented against some stuff that he was
doing and she tried to get him
to chill out and he turned on her and
[ __ ] demoted her ass and [ __ ]
reassigned probably all she said too was
just like hey honey can you be like five
percent less of an [ __ ]
maybe I think there's more to it than
that it was probably like probably I
think you know because the way women are
[ __ ] is probably oh the way women are
yes
probably more along the lines of uh
you're overstepping this [ __ ] these
people are going to turn on you and
[ __ ] throw you out of here if you
[ __ ] keep acting well so the way
women are is like we call [ __ ] like you
see it like yeah yeah we see when you're
[ __ ] up she came at it from a
negative point of view
no she probably [ __ ] came at it with
what what the truth was and I was like
hey he's that [ __ ] off no oh I don't
like that well he was like how dare you
[ __ ] jump up and [ __ ] tell me this
[ __ ] you're just an ot5 and I'm an ot9
and I run I'm the [ __ ] cob of [ __ ]
Scientology and you [ __ ] spoken out
of line and you're not [ __ ] you know
what I mean and I'ma have to punish you
for [ __ ] being out of line you know
what I mean [ __ ] I'm the one that
judges that's how that's why I'm cob and
then he goes you're demoted let me give
you a shitty job up there in the [ __ ]
mountains you know it [ __ ] rim of the
Earth or whatever it's called
you're gonna be up there [ __ ] it's
like a campground up in the [ __ ]
Sierra Nevada I mean it's pure this
beautiful up there
she might be glad to get away from his
ass but yeah it's a gilded cage because
you're now up on this [ __ ]
fenced in compound
it's like a ski legit it's like a ski
lodge is what it looks like but then
here's the thing none of those
Scientology outposts their basis is what
they call them none of them have real
functions they're grading papers and
doing busy work and Lawn Care
and [ __ ] they're probably just
hanging they're probably just in there
like making clay figures yeah I
I told that story haven't I yeah so
she's in prison she she's basically
impressed they're all in prison
anybody who and here's the thing hold on
it's real for y'all who don't understand
Scientology and haven't listened to the
long histories of shows that we've had
on about it I've had AGP the angry gay
Pope on here is one of the greatest
Scientology [ __ ] protesters of all
times he's [ __ ] funny as [ __ ] even
though that [ __ ] wishes I was
gay he keeps [ __ ] calling he keeps
going you need to do this you need to go
on more steroids you need to do whatever
I post the pitch because you're not
quite [ __ ] big enough you know he's
gay he's gays he's [ __ ] anyway
anyways
uh what happened what I forgot where I
was see I had distract myself but uh
he distracted somebody else and himself
I distract your videos
well at least you know how it feels yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
I forgot what I was saying he got you
got all distracted by by muscles yeah
you were thinking about being gay and
then you're just like went off on a hole
went on a hole Fantasia yeah
about scientology and what people don't
understand about scientology isn't that
I was talking about you guys can drive
drop it in the comments I feel like that
I've been drinking yeah
Scientology Scientology is [ __ ] um
they're [ __ ] up
but there is like an orange it's like
it's kind of paramilitary in the way
that it does stuff but I forgot I was
getting that
Mr 88 said I listened to your uh Danny
rolling episode last night in which Tom
does an extended Dennis Silence of the
Lamb's impersonation it was particularly
well done and funny yeah we have to go
back and listen to that because I don't
remember that Mr 88 also says as I dozed
off I had this mental picture of having
a formal dinner with my wife as Tom was
just beside the table but instead of a
Swanky violin player he was channeling
Killers both real and imagined
you should write yourself out at least
I'm not cutting some of the top of
somebody's head off that we know of yeah
looking at their brain and frying that
[ __ ] up on a pan and then here you want
some okay here you go
here you want me to cut off your fingers
and your penis and like cook it and feed
it back to you oh it's so chewy yeah
probably should have put it in the crock
pot yeah
Sarah says there's an awesome Channel on
YouTube called Fundy Fridays all she
does is research and rip on horrible
Christian fundamentalists ooh that
sounds like fun that sounds like right
up my alley because one of my favorite
things I think I brought this up before
but one of my favorite uh channels is
nicktoramio and he does uh like movie
things and but they're usually like
shitty like Disney Channel movies like
from the 90s because that's when he was
a kid and but every now and then he does
stuff he has a Pure Flix subscription
and so every now and then he does like
some really [ __ ] up like pure Flicks
movie or TV series and those are the
best those are like so so [ __ ] funny
but yeah he has a great show too but
yeah I always like
we've talked about that before like how
bizarre their [ __ ] entertainment is I
didn't even know I and I saw a video the
other day too about Holy Land Holy Land
Experience yeah it's going on now did
you know that yeah but like I didn't
know yeah that it was not open anymore I
got the details on it yeah yeah I didn't
tell you well I watched the video but I
don't remember like because you did like
a 45 minute like deep dive
whole history of experiences like
Christian Disneyland but it was a cheap
version of it but yeah like only like a
one percent as fun as that sound yeah it
it was well made but it was kind of
small
um and you went through
basically what it was is they brought
churches in I mean because the public
didn't really care about it they bring
churches in and they would go and they
would watch all these little live-action
reenactments of things from the Bible
and the Christians liked it you know I
actually wouldn't mind going to see it
back in the day
but the guy that owned it died
okay he died that's why it shut down
and it evidently was kind of slightly in
I think it was in debt
and the guy who owned its wife
um
she still owns it but closed it down
they don't have enough operating money
to keep the [ __ ] running and she is now
kind of like dating and or living with
the dude who played Jesus
they had like a main Jesus dude who who
went around and played yeah he got like
kind of famous he was like their main
Jesus yeah he was their personal Jesus
yeah yeah person
and the the wife the white the the the
Widow of the owner was she the big hair
woman I think she is yeah and she's like
hooked up with Jesus and they don't need
the place they're probably gonna sell
that [ __ ] off
I think they already have
um I have to remember because like I
said [ __ ] man I think it just came up on
because I subscribed to some other
channels like there's one called like
what's it called like defunct land and
there's some other ones like that
um so it just came up in my
recommendations and I was like oh holy
land I've been wondering what the [ __ ]
was the deal with that uh because I you
know we would pass it sometimes like on
I-4 because you could see the signs and
everything and I thought it was still
open but I thought it was still open but
just for like um by appointment only
like you could just have like your
church group was going there but
apparently it hasn't been but I think it
closed in 2018 actually maybe or maybe
it was a little bit later than that but
Mr 88 goes her own personal Jesus yeah
yes
are there different kinds it's Chris in
front of us of course there are there
are very many different kinds of
Christian fundamentalists no said no
what he said was uh all the horrible
Christian fundamentalists that is there
a different kind of person other than
horrible ones
no there aren't yeah uh grab their
stammer which job would be worse wearing
a Chewbacca costume every day in 100
degree Heat at Disney or wearing a
Pharisee costume every day 100 degree
you know Holy Land oh Chewbacca would be
worse yeah I'd rather [ __ ] be a
Pharisee I mean the thing and the thing
to about Disney I don't know if they if
this still applies but I think that a
lot of the costume characters at Disney
they usually even had to like share
undergarments and things like that yeah
yeah and they and yeah you had to like
walk around the park like all they like
in August when it's like 200 degrees in
this big [ __ ] fur suit they are
cooled but I don't really I mean in this
humidity I don't think it would make
that much of a difference yeah grafters
I talked to [ __ ] Steve he
um I told I told Steve to hook up with
you you need to teach him uh some of the
[ __ ] have radio skills need to get
him on a hand I told I told Steve he
needed to get a uv9r that battlefeng uv9
I got [ __ ] two of those the
waterproof ones they're only [ __ ]
like 35 bucks right now
and I was checking those things out
you know it's radio on a chip it's not
as nice as my bow thing but for the
dollar per dollar that [ __ ] battery
and the waterproofness and
as long as you got decent accessories
they got those Motorola you can accept
Motorola accessories that's a nice
little radio man that's what I told him
to get get it I get the ham and the gmrs
and some people have said you could
crack the the the the ham version to to
uh to program in gmrs frequencies into
that thing but that's that's between us
go ahead I'm done
[Laughter]
yeah I'm just trying to remember what it
was I was [ __ ] getting at [ __ ] yeah
what were you getting at I was getting
at something I couldn't tell I
distracted myself
well at least you can't blame me I mean
you probably still will but but
you just said uh grafter said Stephen I
just had beers in an Irish Pub
Ham radios and prepping was one of many
topics okay there you go because I told
him to ask you about that yeah so Tom
was behind it all along
he's the puppet master I said that uv9r
is the way to go for the money
yeah
along with catching up on the last 30
plus years yeah that's a lot of God damn
yeah I don't even remember most of what
happened over there for the last 30
years to be honest with you
I don't know I have a weird thing where
it's just kind of like
I don't know I'm more forward-looking
person I don't really
once shit's in the past I don't really
like I don't really think about it all
that much anymore you know yeah
I mean I still do sometimes but not
usually yeah not usually
I got I got [ __ ] I gotta I gotta do in
the future I'm not worried about what
happened back then
um what was I gonna say um
oh um remember how they said that they
found out who sumberton man was oh yeah
you look into it I did look into it now
they don't know exactly like who killed
him or how he ended up there but they
absolutely did find out uh who he was
and no he was just like he was an
electrical engineer okay
um and he was from Australia he wasn't
like anything they don't I don't think
he was a spy but they said that he got
divorced like 1947 so like a year before
he died and then they don't really have
any record of where he was like for the
year after that so no one's entirely
sure like where he was during the year
prior to him getting killed so but they
did find out who he was I mean with 99.9
what about the um
what about all the little books and the
colors well that's what they're trying
to figure out now they said well now
that we know who he is okay then it will
probably be easier to like go and
investigate all the weird [ __ ] like
about his death like what the [ __ ] was
he up to so you know because when they
didn't know who he was before that made
it a lot harder are you ready to do a
show on it or yeah
um I want to give them more time because
really all they have is they figured out
his name like they did and they did it
through DNA like they found like his
you know just distant cousins he had
distant cousins that were still alive
like in Australia and um they were able
to like pinpoint it down to like the one
person that you know didn't have a death
certificate or blah blah so they
actually found out who he was but like I
said they don't really know much beyond
that yeah so I was kind of thinking
about that before we did the show
because I was watching a video about it
from the news like in Adelaide or
whatever
and uh speaking of spy stuff
I was what uh I saw um
Brandon tennille's video
came up with his review of 007 her honor
Her Majesty's Secret Service
Brandon did on our Majesty Secret
Service I don't remember him doing that
not Brandon no no Oliver uh who Oliver
Oliver not Brandon yeah Oliver did that
because I was like Brandon Brandon
usually does like like shitty just like
like Godzilla what's his name Oliver
Harper Oliver Harper yeah
and uh he said it's one of the best Bond
films and it's it's it's got that one
actor I forgot his name that's the only
[ __ ] movie he did of yeah Telly
Savalas plays um [ __ ] blofeld
and he he recommends yeah that's right
he says it's good he says it's real good
and he said that uh a lot of the stuff
that you saw later on in the Daniel
Craig movies and [ __ ] kind of was taken
from that movie which is it's kind of
like a standalone but then Sean Connery
came back after anyway he only did one
movie
yeah yeah but he said it was good so
it's real good it says it's kind of like
it got panned at the time that it was
released
but over time people have kind of
accepted it as like one of the best
James Bond movies
I like to see it so at any point at any
point in the movie does blofeld say who
loves you baby I'm like suck on a
lollipop I don't know because that would
be super funny if that happened
acronistic probably Oliver Oliver likes
telescope yeah George Lazenby that's the
thing lesson B yeah
uh who was not an actor this is his
first movie and he [ __ ] talked his
way into that role
and he was Australian yeah and he became
an actor afterwards based on he made a
lot of bunch of money in real estate
that's jumping in at the deep end didn't
it yeah he just talked his way into
being double 07.
come on
and then Telly Savalas was [ __ ]
blofeld and um Oliver Harper liked liked
Telly savalas's take on blofeld better
than than um the dude from [ __ ] uh
uh he was the guy who played the doctor
from [ __ ] uh
Friday the 13th or excuse me
um Donald Pleasence Donald Pleasence
yeah not Friday 13. Halloween Halloween
yeah yeah you see he liked him a little
better than [ __ ] Donald
pleased you know that movie with the guy
the dude you know the thing dude the
dude with the dick
yeah dude
you know
well it's only just because I mean I've
known you for such a long time you know
what I'm thinking that usually I know
like what not always but like sometimes
I know like what tracks your mind is
going down so I'm just kind of like so
I'm right there but then usually I mean
I've started forgetting names too
sometimes but yeah
uh you know what I mean uh lion Explorer
said okay I'm so stoned I can no longer
type coherently it's okay I wish I could
drink once again I don't know you seem
to be doing pretty good you doing good
dude I mean
it's grammatically correct we're drunk
y'all are drunk it's [ __ ] Friday hey
I'm not drunk anyway I'm still on my
first one I haven't even finished it
tomorrow me and Jen will probably go out
to the club we'll see yeah we might go
out tomorrow yeah it's this close
yeah I mean it's not close but it's easy
to get to yeah on the toll roads yeah
it's an easy drive and I do like I I
didn't know how I I didn't know how I
felt about the venue like when we first
got there but the more times we go there
the more I like it it's still weird it's
private though like nothing's gonna I
mean nothing's ever gonna top their old
location because I mean that was iconic
downtown yeah that was iconic and it was
just like
you know
um so it was a little bit weird like and
it was a little bit weird to get used to
but
yeah I think I like it one it's a lot
easier to get to you don't have to go on
I-4 you can go on like the toll roads
and there's nobody out of out and about
so it's a lot safer and you get there
and there's like nobody around it's not
downtown it's like in the [ __ ]
Warehouse District
it's pretty awesome it's like pretty
quiet you can go hang out in the parking
lot and talk or smoke or drink in your
car and then go back in and dance
yeah it's pretty awesome pretty awesome
so you know lion said I'd have been a I
said Tom would have been a gall
Gladiator yeah hell yeah
and Graham says I told him that we you
were the Catalyst for all getting back
together all stuff yeah oh yeah he's
been around you guys you all need to get
together in these hard times so you know
who you could trust
get some radios and talk to each other
and radios and guns and [ __ ]
cryptocurrency you can go yeah what's up
and then [ __ ] Mr Eddie says Tom ties
together ham radio I think the fan
founder of Chris of the Christian Park
was Ken am yeah did he found that one I
thought he founded that weird like uh
creationist Park in where the [ __ ] is
that Kansas it's in the midwest
somewhere I've never been to that one I
don't think he did Holy Land though I
think the thing behind Holy Land which
actually I didn't really know although
maybe you told me this and I just forgot
was actually the guy who started it was
actually a Jewish guy who had converted
to Christianity yeah so his whole goal
even though he never really said this
but his whole goal with holy land was to
I don't know if he necessarily wanted to
like convert Jews to Christianity but
that was kind of like what his maybe and
because when the Park first opened and I
totally did not remember this because it
was so long ago that it wasn't even on
the radio radar for me but they said
that a lot of like Jewish people in
Orlando like protested it because they
were like [ __ ] off like we don't want to
be [ __ ] converted and they thought
that that was kind of like what the dude
was trying to do with the park well
what's funny is that that was the
Genesis of Christianity anyway you go
back to [ __ ] first the second century
well yeah
Christianity was created by Jews that
had grown up inside of the Roman
influence inside of the Roman Empire
it was Judaism part two
elections it was a Judaism that was
acceptable to Romans it had become very
romanized
Jesus and a lot of stories about Jesus
the reinterpretations of [ __ ]
Hercules and
um what was his name
um [ __ ] another one of the Roman gods
I'm thinking of well which one there was
that oh man the one that was [ __ ]
never mind Simon the god of parodies no
I'll remember it when I can
but most of most of the the uh most of
the Christian scriptures are basically
Jews Roman Jews
trying to convince
Jews to convert
to Christianity well like I said that
was kind of seemed like that was the
mission statement but like the low-key
mission statement of Holy Land yeah even
though they didn't want to come out and
say it because they're like oh
everyone's welcome yada yada but um
Dionysus that's what I was thinking
about Jesus is partially a copy of
Dionysus the party God yeah partially
well he did a lot of other stuff though
he was all the magnanimous giving and I
know yeah so uh mythicism is which I'm
big into mythicism you can go look at
[ __ ] Dr Robert M price we've had him
on the show before
he'll tell you all about mythicism and
you'll see that Rome excuse me the uh
Christianity is a Roman religion
it's a Roman religion but it uh the
Baseline is uh Judaism Jews who who grew
up in Rome
making a new religion that was more
politically correct in in the in terms
of Rome because you live here now not
over in Judea and you know this [ __ ]
become more Roman and
the Jewish god is Roman now it's a Roman
Style version of the Jewish god that's
all it is and it's not unique
the Egyptians in Rome were doing the
same thing
they had uh mithras you know there were
a couple two different versions of
mithras the Egyptian version and the
Roman version and there were two
different versions of Judaism the Jewish
version and the Roman version and that
that's what Christianity is and this
goes back to the Germans of Tibet cross
and the mustache man the problem the
reason why they did not like
Christianity because it was Jewish it
was just Jewish they didn't like it
they thought it was a Jewish creation
they wanted it out of Europe
it says uh was that Kent hovind you were
thinking of yeah yeah that's right I
think it was Kent Hoven that did that
but wait didn't Ken Ham have one too
because I thought they had the
creationist Park and I remember that
because they had the um was like a
Triceratops with a saddle on it because
they think that dinosaurs and humans
exist at the same time yeah and like
cavemen Road dinosaurs well obviously
but uh so so they built a whole park
about it but didn't one of them maybe it
was Ken Ham didn't they have like an arc
Park I don't know if they ever built it
but I think that he was like raising
money to like build like a life-size
Noah's Ark that was gonna have like
a theme park kind of situation inside of
it I could I don't know it's been like a
while since I read about that but
we have here in well not here but on the
way to Tampa
is it in Lakeland I want to say
there is like a dinosaur theme park
that's really old and it's just I don't
think it's open anymore but it's just
like you can see some of the dinosaurs
from like the side of I-4 and it's like
I always kind of like look for the
dinosaurs every time we go to Tampa but
I don't think it's open anymore I don't
think it's creationist I just think it's
just like you know I just think it's
just a regular park for little kids like
if they're on the road and you know
Glenn little jumps in no knowing all
about mithrans yeah exactly and then
mythrism and Christian early
Christianity joining together with the
idea of [ __ ] the apostles in the in
the Last Supper in the Last Supper The
Last Summer the last Supple that's
that's the porn
you know the last supper and the [ __ ]
and the disciples you know that's that's
mithras all right you say the most
ridiculous
[Laughter]
and then you find out that all those
really
real Christian
monasteries and the really old Christian
churches are all built upon mithraic
temples that the church bought
yeah like in the first and second
century as it grew
and you find that the [ __ ] Cult of
mithras and and Cult of Jesus merged
early on first second century
so
it is what it is
you know it is what it is
it was business
John Smith said Kent Hoven had dinosaur
Adventureland yeah that's what I was
thinking he now has a YouTube channel
after getting out of prison which one is
it that hangs out with uh the kid that
used to be on Growing Pains banana man
was that Ken Ham no I remember the one
that said creation is a must or yeah
yeah creationism must be true because
bananas are perfectly him I'm like uh
you know that humans cultivated those
right like wild bananas didn't look
anything like that bananas are man-made
they are yeah a lot of the [ __ ] that
[ __ ] these dudes
[ __ ] chickens are man-made have you
seen what a chicken looked like a
hundred years ago you were like that's a
chicken [ __ ] [ __ ] been the
size of a pigeon
well yeah I mean the wild version like I
said wild versions of bananas don't look
anything like no just like the wild
versions of corn like corn on the cob
don't like anything like it I mean man
like people cultivated that and then
there are versions of bananas that
Americans will never see in Brazil they
had a little bitty bananas they're like
the size of a finger they were beautiful
and they tasted like uh like an apple
that the texture but that sounds kind of
better actually for example there were
little bitty tiny little miniature
bananas
they just yeah because
the banana that you're seeing that's the
very common bulk version of the banana
here in the United States you go into
[ __ ] South America there's like
[ __ ] 50 versions of those things
you know well yeah that's kind of the
thing it's like a lot of the produce
well a lot of the produce you to get in
the U.S is like big agribusiness so a
lot of it is just like a few strains
right of you know what I mean whereas
like in other parts of the world there's
a lot of there's a lot of different
varieties Like Somebody went past with
their stereo blaring yeah it's like it
was really loud but yeah there's like
Brazil had [ __ ] like at least five
big versions of them I mean it's gotten
better like nowadays I kind of feel like
when I was a kid growing up like you go
and there was like one kind of banana
like two or three different kinds of
apples like stuff like that but now
there's like a lot more I mean there's
way more [ __ ] in the produce section
than there was when I was a kid you can
make any kind of fruit you want same
thing with animals if you got time you
can make any kind of animal you want
there's a selective breeding I mean if
you got time yeah
the cows they that we're eating now are
much bigger than they used to be and
it's the same with the chickens
the sanderson's farm chickens from
Mississippi should not exist
we try to send centers and Farms
chickens to Russia and they send them
back this has got to be something wrong
a chicken is not that big
and they're right
the Sanderson Farm chicken is so big it
can get [ __ ] gigantic [ __ ] three
times bigger than a [ __ ] wild chicken
or what they descended from three times
big they're so big that they'll break
their own legs just running around so
they keep them in boxes
because they can reach maturity in about
a month
and I don't understand that's uh that's
selective breeding and hormones
steroids getting them that big that's
probably not the best idea I don't
really I don't [ __ ]
I don't hold anything against the
Russians about saying no I can't be a
chicken saying that [ __ ] no thanks the
meat isn't that good on a Sanderson Farm
chicken is tough
but it's big
you just gotta cook it a lot well yeah
the all they want is quantity enough
it's just quantity yeah Linux Warrior
said homeschooled Ultra Christians
actually use Kent seminars as science
fact yeah that's right uh he's got all
that creationist [ __ ] and they yeah
if you homeschool your kids enough yes
they use that Kirk Cameron that's that
bitch's name I couldn't remember uh his
movie Saving Christmas is annual viewing
in my home I kind of want to watch it
I've seen clips of it and I've seen like
um I've seen like people's like people
mocking it and I think when I watched uh
or listened to the podcast got awful
movies and they kind of do that too like
where they just mock like [ __ ] uh
super Christian movies and I think they
did an episode on saving Christmas and
it sounded
entertaining and also horrifying at the
same time so I don't know maybe one of
these days if I have some brain cells to
kill I'll watch it but it'll probably
just make me mad
we can bust we can bust on Christians
that's fine but I'll also bust on
[ __ ] people who are who aren't
religious at all that believe in
theistic [ __ ] Concepts uh they're
they're not just
[ __ ] religious religions there's
[ __ ]
what do you call them secular religions
like they got a whole bunch of people
out there that think that carbon dioxide
is poisonous it's not carbon monoxide is
but not carbon dioxide as part of the
carbon cycle
if you increase the carbon dioxide what
will happen is you'll [ __ ] you'll
you'll get increased temperatures
but you'll also get increased plants
they'll produce more oxygen it won't end
the Earth there's just too much goddamn
evidence it's still a trace element as
it is now but you go to any University
and they'll tell you oh no carbon
dioxide is terrible no it isn't they've
been paid to say that you got to look at
the [ __ ] details
during the dinosaur age the carbon
dioxide levels were [ __ ] far above
what they are now far above
and the place was a [ __ ] lush
tropical environment you had a smaller
poles true but it didn't it didn't
[ __ ] you didn't you didn't end up
with Kevin Costner's water world and
they had smaller poles back then it was
just
the coastline was different
but if you have a higher carbon dioxide
content you'll have [ __ ] [ __ ] tons of
plants it'll be tropical everywhere and
raining everywhere it'll be like the
[ __ ] monsoon season and if that [ __ ]
gets too far you'll have an ice age
because you have so many clouds you'll
deflect the [ __ ] solar radiation back
out into the Earth and the temperatures
will fall so yeah there is a [ __ ]
balance you got to look at
but we're nowhere near
that Tipping Point of what people this
global warming [ __ ] they're talking
about that's all fake it's about making
money it is fake I [ __ ] looked I've
looked at the real data yeah okay okay
it's fake all right it is uh okay
they can take a lot more CO2 like seven
times that's what it was in the dinosaur
okay I'm sure you know better than all
the scientists in the world they've been
paying go make me a drink they've been
paid all the scientists in the world
it's not all the Sciences it's the ones
that worked on it and they were paid to
find that conclusion okay they were okay
yeah
Tom knows everything I do no you don't
grampton says a former landlord once
lend me Kirk Cameron's movie firewall is
it firewall or fire proof
uh saying it was a must-see movie about
marriage I made it about 10 minutes in
before putting a porn on yeah well isn't
okay I haven't seen that movie either
but I think I also saw the breakdown on
uh god-awful movies isn't one of the
plot points of that that Kirk Cameron is
a porn addict is that or is that another
because I think he did another
he did one called I think it was called
fireproof and then he did one another
one about marriage I think that I think
was called war room I want to say or
something like that
and in one of those he was a porn addict
but of course they couldn't like show
any porn they just had to like do it in
a real slick sort of way but yeah is
that the one that I'm thinking of I
think that's the one I'm thinking of
I think that's what I'm thinking of
talking about Kirk Cameron's movies
I kind of want to watch him but then I
kind of want to don't because
I think I like it better when
when I could watch like God Alpha movies
and stuff like that where people are
just like making fun of it because if I
actually just watched it I'd probably
just end up getting like really mad and
like yelling at it and turning it off
Jonathan John is saying Tom you know
that 99 of the scientists disagree with
you 99 of the scientists that disagree
with me were paid and they're hoarse if
you actually look at them they're not
climbing people they're just [ __ ]
people they're Democrats they'll say
anything so am I yeah but you'll just be
paid to say that yeah I'm paid to say
all this stuff the [ __ ] data the CO2
levels were much higher millions of
years ago please stop they were they
were much much higher millions of years
ago and you still you still had life on
the planet
you still had life on the planet
they were like [ __ ] Many Times Higher
and what it allowed is allowed for more
plants it allowed for insects to be get
Giant
it's just not a poison it's part of the
carbon cycle
you could look at it in a certain way to
say that the planet is dying
what's up Pookie you could say that the
planet is dying because it used to be
even more Lush you have more carbon
dioxide
more oxygen a much thicker and uh uh
[ __ ] uh what do you call it
atmosphere don't believe what those
people say
you gotta look at real scientists the
real science says that they're full of
[ __ ]
ah
yeah Grant assist Iceland was tropical
back in the day it was it was and a lot
of that had to do with the atmosphere
was a lot thicker it was a lot denser
back then
are you done yeah it was rich in carbon
dioxide and oxygen it was it was don't
annoy me again you annoyed me on
Wednesday don't [ __ ] annoy me all
right God damn it yeah
ah
stop it they said stop whining up top
hold on nobody wound him up he was just
like that and I was just kind of like oh
God it's not gonna be any fun I know it
I look forward to doing these shows but
it's like when he's in this mood
and when he's been out all afternoon
drinking already and it's just like he's
already getting all [ __ ] and I'm just
like oh God this is like not gonna be
any fun for me I can tell
yeah John Smith says lifelong atheists
here same here um
yeah I think I figured that [ __ ] out
when I was uh
10 11 12. and I'm just like yeah that's
a bunch of crap what what are you saying
I'm not something else okay
I believe it's
even no you don't yes I do I believe
it's not I don't I believe in base
science though yes I do believe inside
she's she doesn't know what I'm talking
about I've been besides no you don't not
what not what those [ __ ] say they
just say anything you pay him to say
good they do I'm just you know what this
is a boring topic to me and it's like
dude and nothing
and like I said there's no point there's
no point I've learned this like I've
known him for a long time there's no
point in like arguing with him because
he thinks he's right about everything
and so if you argue with him about it
he's just gonna be like
so it's just there's no point there's no
point
you know what I mean there's no point
arguing because he thinks he's right
about everything uh next two hours are
gonna be a hoot yeah probably
um this is Cherry yeah I'm just well I
mean I think I got I was getting kind of
like annoyed on Wednesday night like not
super annoyed but because we were trying
to do a show about like a very serious
like True Crime case where eight young
people were slaughtered in Cold Blood
and I'm just like at some point I don't
even remember how we started off on that
tangent but he's like showing like old
goth pictures of himself I'm like
can we like can we talk about the
murders and like not make this all about
you but it's just I don't know I was
just getting annoyed but not that
annoyed
um but yeah so I already started this
show like kind of because he already
said like before we started oh I was you
know I'm gonna be a handful and I'm just
like oh oh goody it's gonna be like that
and like I said the drunker I get like
the less patient I get to so there was
gonna be that also
um John Smith said when it comes to
atheism as a kid I pretty much figured
that Santa and God were the same yeah I
think what got me to that conclusion was
not so much Santa Claus I think it was
um
well I was real into Greek mythology
when I was a kid
um you know when I was I started reading
it and then like in 18 in 81 I saw a
Clash of the Titans which I was like
super super into and the more I started
like reading about it I'm like wait a
minute
like thousands of years ago like people
actually some people actually believe
this was true just like people believe
like religions are true nowadays and I'm
just like oh there's no difference so
yeah I think I was maybe like Channel 11
when I figured that out
lion X says this is a cool live stream
we need you and Tom and combination yeah
I mean
I mean to be honest I do like that I do
my own channels now because
um it's kind of I mean it's nice to just
be able to talk and I can stay focused
on a topic usually uh you know and not
go off on a bunch of tangents and I kind
of like that better like to just sort of
like follow my own stuff instead of
you know sometimes like I said so this I
don't mind the Side Tracks because like
I said we don't like we can just talk
about whatever and I'm not concerned
about it but when you do the Regular
Show I usually do try I'm at least
trying to like get all the information
in and so it gets kind of like
frustrating if I can't do that but
I know you know it's at least I have my
own [ __ ] now oh by the way
um if you haven't okay I don't know if
you guys saw this but I think somebody
asked I don't remember who it was but
somebody asked about the shirts for the
scare salons I see I just got that
yesterday or the day before so that's
the one that's the ladies one
with the with the scoop knives well it's
not a scoop neck because they're out of
those but that's like the v-neck and
they have regular ass shirts too there's
mug and there's mugs and [ __ ] but
on folks running up the [ __ ]
tree and fighting it and trying to get
yeah in the damn department whether I
don't have time for that yeah I know I
don't have time for to come up with it
to get up inside the apartment with the
cat but on Monday
um you know so if you haven't gone and
subscribed to my scarcelon channel do
that because it's all I've got a bunch
of videos up there now but I also have a
site just scaresalon.com and there's
like a bunch of movie reviews and I put
new [ __ ] up on there every day like a
new post and Monday I'm starting another
YouTube channel uh that's gonna be all
true crime and I also have a website for
that it's done like I have a bunch of
[ __ ] up on it but it hasn't gone I
haven't done public yet but I'm gonna do
it Monday August 1st and that's going to
be like all unsolved murders
and it's called a crime immemorial so
that's going to be a whole site and a
whole new channel I have two videos made
for it I'm gonna put up two a week and
I'm gonna put up two a week on scare
salon and I'm gonna keep doing all this
stuff on 13 clock too so okay like I
said I just make I like to make a lot of
work for myself Mr 88 is saying what I'm
missing is the amount of [ __ ]
pollution and the rate that it's been
dumped in over the past 2000 years and
blah blah blah no I'm not missing that
you're overestimating all that I [ __ ]
looked at the data that's nothing
compared to what's happening around the
Pacific Rim with the volcanic activity
uh things like meteor impacts that have
happened over the [ __ ] hundreds of
thousands of years
uh [ __ ] that happens inside of just
plate tectonics no no there hasn't been
any impact
proof is go look at Plymouth Rock
Plymouth Rock looks exactly the way it
looks now than it did back in the
[ __ ] 1500s nothing's changed there
hasn't been much of an impact
what makes big impacts are things are
giant like [ __ ]
eruptions of super volcanoes and [ __ ]
meteor impacts that's that that'll make
a difference
but that's happened many times it goes
back to Baseline it might take thousands
of years but it'll eventually go back to
Baseline no I'm I'm just
you could take the entire Earth's
population and [ __ ] put them all in
LA
if they were [ __ ] side by side
there's just not that many people
we're not making a big enough impact
we're making an impact but it's just not
big enough
and it's nowhere near as bad as it was
in the 70s I remember what it wasn't as
soon as I was a kid I could barely
[ __ ] breathe in L.A with all the smog
and [ __ ]
it's just gotten a lot better
we've got to get off a [ __ ] planet
that's a secret
[ __ ] the Earth we're gonna use this [ __ ]
up we got to colonize other planets go
Interstellar go to other [ __ ] planets
we gotta spread like a disease this [ __ ]
here is [ __ ] unlimited [ __ ] space
it's everywhere
we got we run this [ __ ] we either run it
or it runs us it's only two things yeah
it's only two choices it's gonna be all
right
your answer said some lesser known
serial killer topics for your new
channel the Ypsilanti killer yeah I
wrote that down
uh for one for so if we don't do it on
this on the main show then I'll do it on
the other one Oakland County uh is that
that's Michigan right uh killer and Carl
Watts you killed eight of yeah yeah yeah
I think I have him written down but I'll
write it down again because I know I
have the Ypsilanti killer because I
remember somebody said that about but I
remember like it's just it's crazy how
many [ __ ] now somebody on Wednesday's
show said about Pedro Lopez
uh that's a real killer and I put him in
the poll
that went up this morning so if you're
on patreon which you should be
um you can vote in the polls for the
topics for the week and also for the
movie retrospective and that's about all
you can vote for right now but you know
because
the other shows we do we don't we never
know like what movies we're gonna do so
you know but I don't remember what
movies I put in the poll but I remember
that I definitely put Pedro Lopez in
there
John Smith it's a paraphrase Red Dwarf
humans are the reason that other planets
avoid being near the Earth don't go to
your Earth it's got humans right I
wouldn't have to hang out with us if I
was an alien but um well the thing is we
were watching uh The Unexplained last
night and I had fallen asleep like
during the UFO one because I don't know
why but like UFO [ __ ] just like is
really boring to me but um so that one
was like kind of a boring episode and
but I watched the end of it because I
felt like you know I gotta watch the end
of it and I was kind of thinking to
myself
I don't know I kind of feel like if I
was aliens I'd just be like flying by
Earth being like man [ __ ] that place we
don't want to go there a lot of the
alien
stories that you see on TV or the
[ __ ]
first of all they're misrepresented
when you look at the television series
they don't quite tell it the way the
witnesses do
they definitely don't show the proper
video
to match the story that they're talking
about like when they talk about the Tic
Tac UFO yeah they did a segment they
always show another video
okay and it was the video that was taken
by another pair of 80 aviators they came
back later and saw that that is not the
Tic Tac that the [ __ ] main witness is
talking about all right they and then
another a good example would be the
Phoenix Lights
and talk about the Phoenix Lights but
they never show the real Phoenix likes
video because it's not very impressive
what they show is they show a video of
flares
I know but I think it's so much that
because well we don't have any good
video of the real thing so here's the
other Flair so let's show the flares
because at least that looks like
something yeah but the thing is that
totally mystery yeah
what the [ __ ] case was
I have a video of the real Phoenix
Lights I've sent it to people who
listened to the show I've sent it to
xanada I sent it to uh uh
to a couple other people I sent it to
[ __ ] cotterbox lawn and it's hard to
find that video on YouTube because it's
not impressive looking
the real Phoenix Lights video just a
[ __ ] grainy video of a triangle of
Lights
but it's far more convincing when you
look at it in that context when you look
at what the flares video
you're like yeah that's pretty
impressive but that is not what they're
talking about that is not the Phoenix
Lights that was flares
okay it makes you wonder if there's a
[ __ ]
an effort to to cloak or to disguise
these cases
because there's a couple cases
that impressed me there's three of them
that stand out the Phoenix Lights case
the real Phoenix Lights not the [ __ ]
flares okay
thousands of people called in and saw
that cops saw that another one would be
the triangle over Illinois were two
different
police outfits and grampers is in the
[ __ ]
grampers is in the comments section
right now he he's the [ __ ] retired
policeman I'll tell you
have two different police organizations
on two different communication webs
talking about this thing they they're
the chances of just regular B cops
getting together to make this story up
is nil
they saw something flying
they even got a picture of it one of the
cops did it just looks looks like lights
okay in the sky
there was some kind of a [ __ ]
exotic craft there probably
extraterrestrial
I don't think humans could have made it
based upon the performance that are
outlined by the [ __ ] data of the
witnesses okay
third one that [ __ ] freaks me out is
the Tehran UFO
because that was backed up by U.S spy
satellites that something in that area
moved at a high [ __ ] supersonic speed
and there were no supersonic
reconnaissance craft in that area it was
like Mach 8 if I remember correctly
hard to get something I mean the SR-71
Blackboard this is the 70s SR-71
Blackbird only moved to like 3.5 Mach
this was like Mach 8
hmm
I don't think so
and what he did and what [ __ ] Colonel
Jafar is his Colonel and his later I
think he was a [ __ ] captain at the
time
uh what Jafari reported was exotic he
said you know
basically what he's saying what he's
described as something that a
a U.S Air Force craft or a Soviet craft
could not do that and the U.S and the
Soviets would have been the leaders in
aviation at the time of the 70s so what
he's talking about is extraterrestrial
now are they extraterrestrial spaceships
as you know them with little squishy
[ __ ] alien creatures in there
probably not I think they're more like
something AI kind of like the kind of
like the monolith out of [ __ ] 2001
it's probably what it is
some kind of probe
very weird very weird but it's not weird
when you really think about it we're a
Backwater
and and again we're A Primitive species
in a Backwater
and there's older civilizations around
and
they're probably living machines
and I'm sure they've known about this
planet for [ __ ] thousands of hundreds
of thousands or millions of years and we
don't even really register to them
here's an equivalent you're driving down
the highway in your car
and you look on the side of the road and
there's a damn store there's a [ __ ] a
crane sitting there or a [ __ ] Crow
sitting there on the side of the road
watching you
you know what I mean are you gonna pull
over and go talk to that Crow no you're
gonna keep driving
so that's probably all it is we're that
Crow sitting there on the side of the
road
on the side of the freeway
it's going to be something like that
I mean you know they probably find
humans as boring as I find them yeah so
they're going to be like those things we
know about those we are pretty lame so
yeah that's all I do know why like
[ __ ] they'd want to talk to us can't
access uh how do you guys feel about
doing a stranger things show I actually
would not mind doing that
um I would have to like before I did
that I would probably to watch all three
scenes again like just to refresh my
memory because I did watch most of the
new season I still haven't watched like
the last one or two episodes but I kind
of want like I forgot a bunch of [ __ ]
because like a dumbass I didn't watch
season two or season three like before
the new one so I kind of got behind but
like look how behind I am you guys last
year
it was probably like a year a year and a
half ago I bought the new Twin Peaks
newest Twin Peaks which is which what
2019 2018 whatever the [ __ ] it was I
still haven't watched it I bought like
the whole Twin Peaks like in a big box
set
I got it for myself for my birthday or
Christmas or something like that and I
said one of these days I'm gonna sit
down I'm just gonna like binge all the
[ __ ] like I'm gonna watch all of them at
the same time uh you know capping it off
with the new one and I still haven't
done it yet because I just haven't had
time and that is definitely one video I
want to do and I might do a stranger
things one as well because yeah because
I really actually like that show
is that is it lame to not to like that
show is it too popular now am I you know
I don't know I don't know because I do I
never saw the beginning of it everybody
loves it but I never saw it you would
probably really like it I mean but you
probably have to like you'd have to
watch it from the very beginning because
it doesn't I mean you can't just like
Jump Right In because there's like a
whole
because even I jumped right in I've seen
all the [ __ ] and I was just kind of like
wait what what happened with this now
you know what I mean so yeah I mean it's
really good it's really good so what's
the new one new one season's four right
so it's the fourth season I think it's
the newest I gotta go back and watch it
you should probably watch the whole
thing like I said you probably dig it
yeah it's very very well like I said
it's just like an 80s
it's set in the 80s right it's very much
80s right I mean they got like all the
period details like correct and it's
very much like an 80s like Steven
Spielberg
sci-fi horror Adventure right with a
bunch of kids well one of the one of the
channels that I listened to listen to a
lot about movies and
and I really trust them because they're
they're kind of an international outfit
of dudes with good taste which is uh
Midnight's Edge
and they will they [ __ ] talked about
the failure of new Star Wars and
compared that to how great
um
how stranger things got it right
and then they they they Dole out why
it's right
but then they say why Star Wars got it
wrong and why it was wrong so and I
agreed with why star was was wrong well
stranger things in Star Wars are two
completely different things I mean but
they they said that but they were
talking about why one worked and the
other one didn't and they said that the
writing on [ __ ] stranger things was
awesome and that they knew what they
were doing well all the characters are
good
um you know you you really kind of get
into or at least I did like you get
really into like all the characters and
I don't know it's just like a really
good yeah like I said it's like a really
good Steven Spielberg sci-fi adventure
with horror elements yeah well it's an
interdimensional
is what it and they're and there's stuff
about like government conspiracy like um
you know like MK Ultra type [ __ ] where
it's like you know they we had all these
kids that have like psychic powers and
[ __ ] like that so it's like a fire
starter it's very Stephen kingy well
that's kind of why they use that Stephen
King font like for you know it's they're
homaging yeah which is crazy because I
think The Duffer Brothers the guys that
created it I don't even think they were
born in the 80s but holy [ __ ] they
really really did I mean I watched the
first season of that because everybody
told me to watch it so I watched it and
I was just kind of like holy crap this
was exactly it looked exactly like the
80s I was like oh my God that looked
exactly like my house like growing up
like we had that furniture we had those
dishes
that whole thing it was just like they
really really did it good I probably I
would probably like it according to
stranger according to [ __ ] Midnight's
Edge basically they said I would love it
I told you a long time ago that you
would like it but like I said you gotta
kind of there's a lot of
characters and there's a lot of plot
threads so you really kind of have to I
mean it's not like something because I
tried to get I don't know if I've tried
that hard but I tried to get him into
that German series dark yeah
um but that one is like super
complicated I mean you really really
have to that's kind of like stranger
things for I don't want to say stranger
things for adults because that sounds
mean but no I'm just saying it's no I'm
just saying that that's that it's a lot
more like complicated yeah um and like
you had to have like flow charts and
[ __ ] and I was just like wait what
timeline is this because they're like
five or six different timelines see you
really had it but it was really good but
you there was a lot to keep track of
stranger things is a lot more let's it's
a lot more crowd-pleasing like I said
it's a lot more like a Stephen King
novel or you know like a Steven
Spielberg movie from the 80s or
something like that it's very much in
that vein so that's why I was trying to
kind of get you into it and it's I'm not
[ __ ] on it I really like it I really
like it I mean I liked dark as well but
they're similar but they're two
different they're coming at it from two
different approaches you know what I
mean but yeah you probably really really
dig stranger things I would think
because it'll probably like bring back a
lot of memories and [ __ ] like that I
mean all the kids that are in it well
it's funny because when I first started
watching the show I mean they were kids
kids they were kind of like 11 or 12
years old and like now in season four or
whatever the [ __ ] now they're like
awkward teenagers so it's like funny
like watch I was like oh my God they're
in those awkward teenage years but you
know well I guess I got to see it you do
John Smith said I love dark but you need
to take notes as you watch yeah I mean
after I finished that I had to go back
and like because somebody on was it on
Wikipedia or somebody on the thing had
made this massive massive chart that
kind of had all the timelines and all
the relationships between because that
has like people being their own parents
and [ __ ] like that and uh yeah so you
it's a lot to it's a lot to uh keep
track of but if you do keep track of all
of it then it's really really good but
you do have to keep track of a lot so
this reminds me of remember blood
machines I [ __ ] love blood machines I
wish that that would continue but I
think they might have [ __ ] played I
guess that story is done
but if you go on they could expand that
Universe out though if you go on if you
if you if you go on uh [ __ ] what service
was that that they came off of shutter
shutter shutter had a series called
blood machines which is good it was part
science fiction fantasy and part music
video
it's [ __ ] great uh I I visually I
[ __ ] really loved it and it was like
uh
bizarre you know it was just bizarre it
was they had their own take on it
kind of like how Star Wars felt in 77
when it first came out which was brand
new and bizarre and its own take
um well the the the band that made that
music I think it's called blood was it
blood something or other anyway
um Sophie is going to see them
okay yeah I can't remember what they're
called yeah uh yeah they did the music
to that yeah she just messaged me today
said she was gonna go see them and I
think in a couple weeks not in Michigan
but uh yeah so she sent me the flyer and
everything I was like oh man that'd
probably be good blood angle no no blood
blood no that's a blue tangle that's a
that's that's a totally different
totally different band I don't think the
name had anything to do with blood in it
I don't think let me see what she said
not that I not that I'm fine she just
messaged me like a couple minutes
because I remembered like doing research
about it but I don't remember the name
of the band Jasmine said season three of
Twin Peaks is pretty much David Lynch
saying oh you thought my other stuff was
a little esoteric yeah well that's why I
want to see it that's why I want to say
it Carpenter blute
oh that's right yeah yeah Carpenter
blute no brute brute okay brute so that
was it doesn't have anything to do okay
yeah she's gonna see them a couple days
that's what I thought oh see look at
that I was gonna say it didn't have
anything to do with it I thought it was
blood no okay brute Carpenter Brute John
Smith said by the bye uh the makers of
dark have a new show coming out called
1899 it looks promising oh I'll
definitely be watching that because man
I was into that and I watched that I
actually watched the whole thing through
like two times I never did do a video on
it though I don't think did I maybe I
did
I can't remember if I did or not I
wanted to but I don't remember if I ever
got around to it or not but like I said
you really have to like
take notes because that [ __ ] was like
complicated
so stranger things is less complicated
it's like much easier to keep track of
but
it's it but I don't know it's I don't
want to say it's like a similar vibe to
dark but it's
it's kind of the same thing there's no I
don't there's no time travel and
stranger things is there but there is
like an interdimensional
because there's another uh
uh there's like another dimension kinda
it's called the upside down that's sort
of like just right on the other side of
our dimension
and there's like a secretive government
project that they're trying to like open
up a rift
did they open up the rift on purpose I
can't remember was in an accident but
then there were also like experimenting
on like kids that had like psychic
powers and [ __ ] like fire starter
so like I said you'd probably be into it
you'd probably be into it
and has anyone seen the new Argento film
I still haven't yet and I haven't like
I've seen some other horror channels
like review it but I'm like I don't want
to watch it yet because I kind of want
to just come to it like without any
I'm not expecting much to be honest with
you
um I don't think I've seen anything new
of his
since
I want to say well didn't he do that
Dracula movie
whenever the hell that was
with the with the big
praying mantis in it
I don't even think I saw the one that
was just called giallo and when was that
2009 I don't know
I didn't I didn't love it
I love it but I I mean I didn't love the
last step that I saw I didn't like
mother of Tears either
which was what 2007. I want to say that
was 2007.
I was like really looking forward to
that because it was supposed to be like
the third one in the three mothers
Trilogy because I'm like oh my God
finally he's finishing it
um but I should have known I knew that
wasn't gonna go but it didn't really I
feel like I don't know I'd have to go
back and watch it because I only saw it
once and I just remember being like [ __ ]
this [ __ ] but
I remember it not it didn't look
anything like the first two like
Suspiria and Inferno I was like you
would think that he if he was
actually gonna make the third one in the
trilogy after all this [ __ ] time you
would think that he'd at least have like
some thematic
you know is it that he'd keep it like
looking like the other ones but it
didn't really look like the other ones
it just kind of looked like a generic
Witch movie Jello was 2009 yeah that's
what I thought I don't think I saw that
one
um John Smith said I saw it it's the
best film Argento has made in 20 years
damning with Fame praise yeah I was
gonna say that's not saying a lot but
because man what was the last good movie
I'm gonna say the last good movie he did
was probably stun doll syndrome
yeah some people could change my mind
but you make that [ __ ] vampire movie
with the stupid ass [ __ ] Cricket
that's what I just that's what I just
said I just said that like five seconds
ago I was sleeping like I guess you were
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] terrible it wasn't
a cricket it was a praying mantis yeah
same thing yeah it's not the same thing
it's too I'm gonna call it a cricket
it's two completely different things
it's a praying mantis yeah that was like
super stupid yeah but yeah I'm gonna say
but I haven't seen all of them but I
think the last one that I liked anyway
like he had some like [ __ ] ones in there
I think I talked about on my flickers
Affair show I think I talked about
trauma which came out in I think 93 that
one's not bad it's not great but it's
not bad
um stendald syndrome I actually quite
liked and that was 96 but
I don't know I think his last great
movie was probably Opera and that was
1987. but stendall syndrome is good
after that
not so much and a couple of those in
there like I hated
like if did you guys see the card player
is that like as bad as I remember I
remember seeing that once being like Oh
my God this is one of the worst pieces
of [ __ ] I've ever seen but you know I
love I love Argento though
John Smith said uh his habit of putting
his daughter in nude scenes is just odd
yeah it is very and the weird thing
about that's and I was thinking about it
too when I was re-watching trauma
because she's supposed to be well she's
has anorexia or bulimia or something
like that in that movie like it's part
of the plot and so there's a scene of
her and I think she was only 16 and I
was like oh they had to put a scene in
there where she's like in the bathroom
and like the guy who like finds her is
like walking by and she's like taping
down her boobs because she like doesn't
like her boobs because she wants to be
skinny and I was like oh you had to put
that in there and also he get she gets
into this relationship with this dude
who's like clearly older like much older
than her and it's like a little bit
weird and uh Dario also puts a lot of
she also gets raped a lot in movies he
directs including stendall syndrome
actually I think she gets raped in that
twice so you know
that's how it is in their family I don't
know it's just it's a weird maybe they
don't have the same [ __ ] kinsky they
don't have the same Hang-Ups man I mean
I don't I don't think I've ever heard
anything about like you know Daria like
doing anything bad and like they seem to
get along and everything but it's just
kind of like he had another daughter too
but I think she I think she I thought
she died actually
that's it I thought he had another
daughter that died
doesn't he had a daughter named Fiore
right but I thought am I crazy did she
die I don't know that's what I'm
thinking uh yeah Mike said I still
haven't seen dark glasses I mean I do
want to see it I do want to see it but
yeah Mike says stand all center of his
last great Argento yeah as like I said I
think probably the last great one is
Opera but I'm not going to argue with
you about stencil room because I
actually do really like that movie a lot
Hugo said I always miss like half an
hour of the show because Camille and you
know you can always watch it Robert says
this channel is real you don't get along
but you have res whatever res is I don't
know respect okay no we get along we get
along we just
it doesn't mean anything me and Jenny
been together over 10 years so we we're
gonna fight that's how it is we lived
together for a long time
yeah I knew her back constantly up each
other's asses like all the time I met
this [ __ ] when she was married to
another man this [ __ ]
don't call me a [ __ ] nah she's cool
no I met her she's married to another
dude we were friends we were friends
when she was still married and then she
divorced a dude then we kind of became
Club Partners where we were [ __ ]
hanging out we were dating other people
and [ __ ] trying to get each other hooked
up and then we kind of became business
partners and just started hanging out
and then then we came we slowly became a
couple over the years after everybody
kept bugging us about it like you guys
are just like together all the time why
like why are you pretending this it's
not a normal relationship we were
friends before we were in a relationship
okay we were friends real friends
yeah but I think that's good though yeah
well I kind of feel like a lot of a lot
of things about with a lot of people is
just kind of like you know you get in a
relationship with somebody that you're
like I don't know maybe you don't know
that dude you don't know that person all
that well you're just like attracted to
them or whatever and then like you end
up just like oh my God I'm like [ __ ]
know this person right you know no we
were friends before we even hooked up so
it's it's a totally different situation
here so I'll [ __ ] call her out on
some [ __ ] and then she'll [ __ ] me up and
then we [ __ ] each other
because we're both mean
we're both mean okay I think I think I
think I'm meaner than you are probably I
think I probably probably is she's weird
I'm not I'm not not physically mean no
I'm not physically mean I don't do I
don't do that like that but I think I
have I have a much like crueler sense of
humor yeah I think so well I think women
are generally better than like generally
like are better at that kind of thing
because a lot of times it's like well
it's not like cool or ladylike to like
get into fist fights
um so you have to like learn to like
[ __ ] yeah wound people in other ways
so we get like a lot better at like
finding people like chinks in people's
armor and like their little
vulnerabilities and stuff now we had a
lot in common and um it wasn't uh wasn't
the sexually driven relationship from
day one it was just that we [ __ ]
liked it we liked [ __ ] each other and
we liked a lot of the same things we had
differences but that didn't have
anything to do with us and it was just
then we got into business together and
one thing led to another and we've been
together for [ __ ] a long time it just
it wasn't something that was planned it
just it just happened and her ex-husband
thought I stole her I didn't steal her
you know see I had already broken I
never really liked I I don't really like
I know we joke about it sometimes and we
and we joked about it like at the time
but and we tell other people that but
it's just a joke because I don't like
that whole idea you can still steal
somebody it's like
if they don't want to go they're not
gonna go with him for about a decade
about no 14 years 14 years right and it
just it ran its course you know what I
mean that's a long time and the thing
about it is like I wasn't mad at him it
wasn't it wasn't one of those things
where like oh you did something bad and
I got pissed at you or anything like
that it was just yeah I don't know like
it was just like after a while it was
just kind of like I'm kind of sick of
this [ __ ] we're both realistic
14 years 10 years that's a long time to
be in a relationship that's longer than
most marriages most marriages five six
years
you know
it's just uh if it lasts that long then
you had a good run
you know
and uh me and Jenny [ __ ] you know we
still get along it's just
business and hanging out and
it's you know we're good friends I mean
it's a good word about it I mean it's a
good thing because well I mean
especially now that I'm working at home
I mean it used to be I worked outside
the house so I had other [ __ ] but now
I'm like in the house pretty much all
the time and Thomas retired so he's home
a lot too so it's just an alarm so we're
kind of like in each other's [ __ ] like
20 so honestly like moving to this house
has been like a bit better because at
least it's close quarters it's not as
close quarters because I feel like for a
long time like at the old house before
we set up the office and all that kind
of stuff I was like doing work like on
my laptop like in the bathroom with
headphones on yeah and [ __ ] like that
because we don't really have any room to
like but now it's like I have my own
room he has like a man cave yeah I gotta
hold downstairs gotta [ __ ] all kinds
of [ __ ] yeah so we have a lot more room
to spread out so we're not like on
constantly on top of each other because
like even if you like the person if
you've been married a long time if you
love the person more than anything in
the world everybody needs time to
themselves you need to have time to like
decompress and like not you know what I
mean we go out we got our own friends
and [ __ ] so you know I mean [ __ ] it's
just it
you know I mean [ __ ] it's
it's not kind of relationship
that I don't think it's all I don't
think it's all that conventional it's to
me it's just normal I guess that'd be a
way to put it I guess it's good
yeah well the thing about it though I
think when you say that it's not
conventional I think that depends on
what conventional is yeah the thing the
thing about it is like a conventional
now I don't even think this that's even
like relevant nowadays I think when we
talk about conventional you're talking
about like [ __ ] from like the old days
yeah and I think a lot of that [ __ ]
about those kind of relationships that's
probably like pretty unhealthy yeah I
don't think that worked either you know
what I mean yeah like I'm not saying
basically but I don't know I just kind
of feel like people should just like be
able to do their own [ __ ] like within
reason obviously don't do something to
like [ __ ] over your your partner or
whatever but you just don't betray or
undermine right but it's but you know
you can have your own friends you can go
out and hang out and [ __ ] like that and
that's like I don't care like like I
said you can go to the Oasis and hang
out I can go to [ __ ] downtown Sanford
and hang out with the girls and [ __ ]
like that we're not doing anything right
like I said the most scandalous thing
I'm doing hanging out with the chicks is
like going to the [ __ ] bookstore
looking for I'm like oh you got any good
horror novels in here because I'm a dork
so you know what I mean but so and
honestly that's what I'm doing too it's
like it's funny because when you came
back in and you thought I was saying
something bad about you I was like I
wasn't really and uh you know when I'm
talking to like other people like at the
club or something like that I'm like you
just not even talking about you I was
like I'm Dorking out about horror movies
or some [ __ ] like that because you don't
like to talk about them all day long
like I do yeah so when I find somebody
that's so I'll even like I'll talk to
Dimitri about horror movies all day what
are you doing
what was that it fell on its own
that was weird wasn't it ooh what are
you getting mad no yes where'd that come
from it just it was just like propped up
in there
okay it just like fell out how'd that
happen I don't know I was in there like
a few days ago because I was looking for
something but that was like several days
ago it was weird that was several days
ago yeah well don't make [ __ ] fall off
my walls again okay other day he got mad
and made my
profonda Rosso poster fall and it's good
a thing I didn't it didn't break because
there's a lot of breakable [ __ ] like in
the path you know what I mean
he needs to stop it with the Poltergeist
[ __ ] he's going to be breaking my stuff
and I'm gonna be happy about it but um
but yeah so I talked to Dimitri about
horror movies because he is super into
horror movies and he likes a lot of the
same ones as me he's rolling to like
yellow movies and stuff so I talked to
him about that I have a friend named
Brian who's like super super into
Mystery Science Theater so like every
time I see him I'm like oh you're going
to like the next Rift tracks or whatever
which like I said by the way if you're
into MST or RiffTrax they're doing a
rift tracks live on
August 18th and I think it's
uh the sequel the Swamp Thing which
would return Us return a Swamp Thing
return something yeah it's the second
Swamp Thing with me which I don't think
I've seen wait is that the one that's
Heather Locklear
okay maybe I did see it that's the one
they're doing August 18th
uh let me see stranger things Lucy but
yeah that's right on the Montauk project
well I think we did we did a show about
that right
did I bring that up on the show cause
yeah
so when did the raunchy bit start Tom
will probably tell you he's drunk enough
[Laughter]
Jack Frost 2 would be a good monster
movie review to end Christmas in July
just saying I mean
we're running out of Christmas movies to
do but did we do Jack Frost and I'm not
talking about Jack Frost the the one uh
uh well there was a Jack Frost with Jeff
Goldblum too but there was one with the
killer snowman which is actually a
[ __ ] classic I love that movie it's
terrible but it's like super super
entertaining it's meant to be terrible
they knew it was terrible but it's like
it's really fun
I don't know if we reviewed that but we
might do it at Christmas this time
because I feel like we've reviewed like
all the good Christmas movies you know
like all the good Christmas horror
movies so now we're gonna have to like
go with like the Shady ones
I don't know if I've seen part two
though
Glenn says uh so when did the raunchy
bit start tell us more what raunchy bits
the raunchy bits
nothing's raunchy
I thought you would jump right into that
nothing's raunchy nothing was raunchy
you're no fun
I don't know what she's talking about
I'm pretty sure that's he Glenn little
you're not really listening are you no I
just jumped in
Joshua says speaking of horror films
today I bought the novelization of Rob
Zombie's Lords of Salem you know I still
haven't seen that movie because I feel
like I don't know one of these days I'll
sit down and watch it but it seems like
one of those movies that people really
really love it or really really hate it
and I'm very hit or miss on Rob Zombie
like I liked House of a Thousand Corpses
and Devil's Rejects and all of that his
Halloween remake can kiss my ass
um other than that
we saw three from Hal right
yeah we saw that uh yeah I think so yeah
that was pretty good
that was pretty good but I still haven't
seen Lords of Salem I don't know
I like Rob Zombie he's cool like he
seems like a cool person every time like
I see him talking uh about horror movies
like in documentaries and stuff he's
very knowledgeable and he seems like
really geeky about it which is cool
but like I said his movies
are Hit or Miss for me like I either
really really like them or I'm just like
really [ __ ] up that's why that's why
I'm so ambivalent about the monsters
thing
it could go either way
it could be the best thing ever and it
could just be like an updating of the
show and it's like super fun or it could
be
like
a massive massive disaster and I'm
really not sure how I feel about how
it's going to come out
you know I can't really tell
from the from the trailer I can't really
tell
I mean you should probably watch the
trailer and let me know what you think
because I was just very I'm sitting
there like thinking about it or what the
monsters
yeah everybody's talking about I haven't
seen you yet
just very very strange
I've never been streaming uh two hours
and ten minutes okay 10 minutes not that
long that hasn't been that long no Hugo
says uh yeah Heather's in Swamp Thing
too okay so I did see it so I did see it
because I remember Adrian Barbeau was in
the first one because we covered that
not too long ago her boobs in it too
well I'm assuming unless she left them
at home I don't know because oh I left
them in my area barbos shows up the
boobs were usually there see that was
the thing see usually not always no no
no like I said sometimes she left him in
her other room then she showed up right
[Laughter]
I mean you know what now every time like
you come in my office to ask me
something like did you bring your dick
with you or did you like leave it yeah
did you leave it in your other pants
that's [ __ ] funny
detachable penis
but we know do you guys remember that
time we know what we're talking about
because they're Adrian Barbeau movies
that include her boobs or Adrian Barber
who's the Tony there were is true I
thought pretty much all of them included
her boots no no some of them don't some
of them don't [ __ ] the best the best
Adrian Barbeau and her boobs movie was
[ __ ] Escape From New York her boobs
were there the whole time
are you saying they should have got
their own credit they should have got
their own exactly starring Adrian
Barbeau
and then the boobs get there it'd be
cool if like each boob had their own
name yeah the boobs get two Oscars
and then the little band on the Oscar
thing also has boobs yeah and then there
are two of them we have like a whole
like scenario that we've come up with
[Laughter]
I kind of like this scenario though she
does have nice boobs yeah
she didn't show her boobs in the fog did
she yeah oh yeah yeah yeah she did kind
of yeah a little bit yeah she did kinda
what else was she in that she showed her
moves in probably um
Creep Show I don't think she showed her
she didn't show her boobs and creatures
no I don't think so that doesn't matter
though because Creep Show is still like
the best movies ever sorry
fight me
easily though I mean it's the best
horror Anthology movie
and I don't think it's ever gonna be
topped although I've seen like some
other really good ones I love horror
Anthology movies but I think that's the
best one Katie says has Tom seen the
trailer for the new Predator movie
called prey yes I have and it looks good
it looks good me a little swole little
swole keeps sending me [ __ ] Clips
updates
it's gonna be good man I think it's
gonna be good and we're hoping that it's
going to be really good
because I think they're taking that down
the direction that Predator has to go
okay
there's a bunch of things that work or
don't work with predator
well worse the Predator it has to be
kind of a [ __ ] forest or jungle
environment
in
in the city environment it didn't work
okay
you already did futuristic [ __ ] you
already did [ __ ] on another planet
so now they're going to do it back
Native American style in America
back in the 1700s or 1500s
and like and you're like yeah okay yeah
let's go there
the Predator's story can be told there
but we got to see how they tell it
and how it goes is it believable is is
there a lot of suspense in it a lot of
action
what are the [ __ ] Predators or yatas
I forgot what they were called what are
they like what were they like in that
era they couldn't have had the same
weapons that was [ __ ] what 300 years
before
so let's see
but according based on
the teasers that I've seen
I'm gonna give it a thumbs up and say
yeah yeah it looks good
what do you think you think it looks
good I think it looks good
John Smith said speaking of Adrian
Barbeau anyone else remember the sadly
short-lived TV show carnival I remember
hearing about it but I don't think I
ever saw it lion X Warrior said
Cannonball Run she showed her boobs the
most yeah that's right yeah that's right
we've been meaning to re-watch that I
kind of felt like we were gonna get
around to re-watching that back when we
were in our Smokey and the Bandit like
Burt Reynolds phase yeah remember that
like a while back when we were doing all
the movies we were watching all like the
foot this welcome movies
um
John Smith said Creepshow has the
youthful Joe Hill that's right yeah he
played the kid in there
that Stephen King's kid and he's also
he's a novelist now well he's been a
novelist for a very long time and
actually I've read
I read horns and I read what was the
other one that needed Heart-Shaped Box
and one of the other ones not Nosferatu
I haven't read that yet I knew they made
a TV series out of that
but yeah I mean you can tell that he's
Stephen King's son uh he's got a similar
writing style but he's got his own thing
going on so I think that's pretty cool
Paranormal Activity next of kin 2021 is
a pretty good witch cult ghost demon
monster film I liked the first
Paranormal Activity but I haven't seen
any of the other ones like I liked the
first one but not enough to like see any
of the other ones you know what I'm
saying I'm not a huge found footage fan
to start with so
but that was one of the better found
footage ones gotta say but I didn't see
any of the other ones
Linux Warrior also says talking of Salem
Salem's Lot with James Mason and David
Soul from Starsky and Hutch yeah we uh
we covered that not too long ago well
and no actually it was a long time ago
because we you have that on
Blu-ray do you not which one Salem's Lot
yeah the original sales got it on
Blu-ray it's good
I really like that I thought they were
great made for TV movie I thought they
were remaking that
well they've remade it already well I
know that we're going to make another
one
yeah prey does look pretty good though
says John Smith okay who said that John
Smith said that yeah to me I haven't I
haven't seen the trailer so I don't know
yeah it looks like it's pretty good all
right we're gonna see
I mean hopefully I mean Terminator is
dead they [ __ ] that franchise up they
didn't know what they were dealing with
they didn't know what
strange that the people that make the
original good ones don't really know
what made those movies great
uh although some people what mitigates
my complaint is that excuse me uh there
are there are some guys from some other
channels that really have studied this
one of them be Med Midnight's Edge
directors have half-lives
they're best when they're young
and idealistic and [ __ ] have a lot of
energy as they get older the [ __ ] that
they make even great names
starts to go downhill
the only guy they're really kind of
[ __ ] kept his heart on over the
[ __ ] years
would be Kubrick Kubrick was always good
even even his last films like Eyes Wide
Shut we're good real good
um but a lot a lot of directors don't
make it over time and Cameron's one of
them
well I kind of feel like the thing about
it is that the the directors that I can
think of that didn't really lose their
Mojo if you want to say that like
Kubrick and David Lynch and stuff like
that who's still around like because
well because they were weird to start
with and then you just got weirder and
weirder right
um Kubrick not so much I feel like his
stuff was maybe not as weird like later
but it's good though but yeah but yeah
his stuff didn't suffer but he
was kind of like his own thing and like
I said David Lynch is his own thing yeah
and I feel like that's kind of the way
to go if you're gonna go that way just I
kind of feel like director's having
half-lives that might have something
more to do with more mainstream films or
things that are kind of like bigger
you know what I mean it's even carpenter
carpenter makes films
up into around
his last real good one
would have been the thing
and I think what happened in the thing
is because the thing got its ass kicked
by each what about Christine oh that was
a that was 83.
it was good but there's something about
I think I I'm going back I'm gonna
[ __ ] I think
Carpenter oh and they live yeah yeah
that was pretty good and that was 87.88
yeah but it wasn't as good as the thing
well very few movies is the thing I'm
gonna say I always had this kind of
feeling that Carpenter really got his
ass kicked because he didn't get
the recognition he should have had or
should have gotten by the thing well
that was his passion project and it was
an amazing movie right and he knew it
was an amazing movie but it took a
people a long time to like realize it
and then like and he got a little bit
the next three or four movies were good
they weren't as good as the thing and
then after that it's almost kind of like
he checked out like [ __ ] the thing
with ghosts of Mars is I don't even
think he really directed that
once again really I mean just
he he started to do schlock
just saying
Cameron was like that
okay Cameron did some really cool [ __ ]
aliens or alien two I'm gonna call it
alien too just despite him
because he's the one he doesn't like
that Alias is [ __ ] a great movie and
[ __ ] he did a lot of work on a lot of
other on a bunch of movies
I even liked [ __ ] Elita battle angel
I thought it was great
I don't think he directed that though I
think he produced that didn't he
I don't remember but he's just
over time just kind of
like they don't give a [ __ ] I mean they
got all their money you know they got
money now they don't really give a [ __ ]
I don't think I think they make their
money and then they stop giving a [ __ ]
and that's kind of what happened with
Terminator
Terminator 2 is some people say the best
action movie I I doubt that I think
[ __ ] Terminator one was the best of
the Terminator movies Terminator 2 was
very good Terminator 3 was okay and then
just no then it just fell apart okay
they made a lot of mistakes with
Terminator it's a dead franchise
but had they watched their p's and q's
and done it right Terminator which could
still be alive today
but they made a lot of novice mistakes
they never should have [ __ ] given a
face to [ __ ] to [ __ ] uh uh uh
[ __ ] Skynet they never there's a
bunch of [ __ ] they should have never
done
it's best to keep people in suspense
don't explain everything don't show
everybody everything don't you know
although there was that one what was the
what was the Terminator movie
that had a damn [ __ ] Terminator
motorcycles in it it had the uh I think
it had guy I think it was Guy Pierce
that was in it I think
I kind of like that one
parts of it I don't remember uh
Terminator is salvation I don't think I
found the Genesis I forgot I don't
remember what they are
but parts of that were good but
they're just telling too much he's
showing too much
well uh and we've said this multiple
times I think that when you're making
movies in the same universe or the same
franchise I think they kind of get to a
point where it's just kind of like we
have to like explain this or that or
we're not going to have like a story and
I think that really like is generally to
the story's detriment I mean unless the
mythology is so broad that you can kind
of expand in a lot of things without
over explaining [ __ ] but I mean horror
sci-fi stuff like that I think that
works better like the less that you
explain like let people Fill Their Own
blanks in people are stupid but they're
not that stupid you know what I'm saying
like people can figure [ __ ] out and
especially like nowadays
with all of the uh you know movies video
games everything they have nowadays like
people are a lot more sophisticated
about their uh entertainment and are
able to follow like really complex
storylines and [ __ ] like that so it's
just kind of like I really think that
you don't need to spoon feed the
audience you don't need to over explain
anything you know like people will
figure [ __ ] out if they can't figure
[ __ ] out they'll be like this is dumb a
little bit and they just like won't
watch it and [ __ ] those people
um you know it's just let people figure
[ __ ] out on their own it's like a lot
more it's a lot more uh rewarding one of
the best series
for sci-fi
multi-movie series was Back to the
Future
some people said well three wasn't again
no three was good too when you get older
you see when you get older and watch
[ __ ] Back To The Future Three no it
makes a lot more sense I didn't like it
that much and I was young younger but
now that now that I see it now now Back
to Future Three was [ __ ] super good
because it wrapped a lot of stuff up
about doc
um that's how you make a long series
that thing was heavily intertwined but
it was credible through the whole thing
it didn't break character it was Back to
the Future though through the whole
thing
they could have done that with a
Terminator series if it was written
right but it just wasn't written right
you know I mean it hacks are writing
that
that's what I'm saying you know
could have done a lot better
Jasmine said cronenberg's latest movie
is pretty good yeah it was I actually
yeah we liked it I actually quite liked
it we liked it yeah which is called
Crimes of the future by the way pretty
good yeah I liked it a lot like I said
if you're gonna be like that well I mean
credenberg is kind of known for being
weird anyway it's just like be weird man
just get weirder as you get older I know
it's hard because most people tend to
like it kind of ossify as they get older
but you really gotta like [ __ ] rage
against the dying of the light man just
get weirder as you get older granther
says my bunion tells me Robert Eggers
will be making good stuff for a while
he's still pretty young though I mean
he's really only on what his third
fourth film so and all of his [ __ ] so
far has been good so hopefully he's got
like a few more like good films in there
Danny says that [ __ ] three was the
best one because they actually went back
in the time in the car at three I
thought Back To The Future Three was
great I liked them all I liked them all
I could watch any of those
and then right along that right
alongside the effect of Back to the
Future series I could watch [ __ ] um
The Frighteners
a very similar kind of movie A
paranormal version Michael J fox and
everything the ghosts and very under
especially the director's cut the
director's cut of The Frighteners is
[ __ ] great
no I recommend it to anybody
and really
based on the weird [ __ ] that's happened
to me in my life and [ __ ]
seeing Poltergeist phenomenon [ __ ]
out of body and near-death experience I
[ __ ] put my money in with [ __ ]
Frighteners as being a kind of like
the way things really is
and then of course you got Jeffrey Combs
you got Jeffrey combs in there [ __ ]
doing it who makes everything better
dinner we're doing an epic
epic [ __ ]
[ __ ] ancient Danvers from the [ __ ]
FBI [ __ ] he's so weird yeah yeah epic
I love it Epic
he's one of those guys and it's it makes
me so sad that like guys like that is
like him and Brad Dourif and Bruce
Campbell yeah and like people like that
that aren't really recognized like in
the horror Community these dudes are
like Legends but I kind of feel like
they're they don't really ever get the
recognition they deserve so I'm like
every so I will see a movie
just because Bruce Campbell is in it or
just because Jeffrey Combs is in it or
just because Brad dwarf is in it because
those dudes are just so [ __ ] awesome
they make every single thing there even
if the movie is shitty they make every
single thing they're in better
Combs is great in both Star Trek [ __ ]
series [ __ ] Star Trek Enterprise
where he played [ __ ] General Charan
one of the greatest Star Trek characters
of all times was [ __ ] andorian
General shran Jeffrey Combs he was a
alien patent the General Patton badass
and then
um did some great [ __ ] and [ __ ] with
the gem hedar where he [ __ ] played
the gem had our [ __ ] hype leader
priest type deal we did a great great
great stuff that he did in that which
was great because
it was kind of lovecraftian both of
those characters especially the gem
Hadar guy that he played
where he's dealing with [ __ ]
five-year-old [ __ ] clone
War alien clone Warriors that could grow
to full
size in five years and [ __ ] they were
dead at 10 years old and [ __ ] and he's
running them and [ __ ] crazy yeah it's
cool real cool well he was in because I
kind of feel like well Jeffrey Combs
gets asked to be like in a lot of crafty
and stuff obviously because he was in
reanimator
um but what he was in one called
Necronomicon right yeah Necronomicon was
great and actually I really like that
it's like an anthology you see it for
free on YouTube Necronomicon yeah I
don't I don't think they licensed it
right but it's a great movie Practical
effects crazy [ __ ] happens it is yeah I
had a good I had a good time with that
yeah necronomical it doesn't really get
brought up much when you talk about kind
of like lovecraftian movies but I
actually really liked it had that big
[ __ ] my ex-wife was in love with
what was his name the big [ __ ]
[ __ ] Big Lick pretty
[ __ ] big lips are pretty much
big lip pretty much he was the one that
we were talking about he was in I know
but I can't remember the movie oh [ __ ]
Danny Rowling said David Warner was in
that film wasn't he which one
Necronomicon
maybe I don't think so or wait a minute
I don't think so I don't know if he's
talking about oh hold on he has another
like comment here Danny rolling says
Jeffrey comes in 2009 Ned of the Living
Dead reanimated is funny as [ __ ] and a
good zombie film Night of the Living
Dead franchise oh you know what I think
yeah we gotta see that one D Wallace is
also in The Frighteners she's great yeah
and I kind of feel like D Wallace is
another actor that that happened to it's
like she's kind of like
I'm sure she's been in some other stuff
too but it's like people know her
because of like Cujo and the howling and
stuff like that but it's like she's so
great and it's just I don't know I feel
like outside of the horror Community
like no one cares and it's like that
makes me really sad I got a huge soft
spot for The Frighteners I'm a big fan
of it I'm telling you and I think I told
you this before if you got money thank
you oh thank you thank you Sly thank you
showing up all right if you like The
Frighteners then you would probably like
this movie that came out in the I think
it was 2013 or 2016. I can't remember
but it's called Odd Thomas yeah and it
was uh it had Anton Yelchin who you know
he passed away like really young like in
this weird freak accident but it was
kind of like a similar it was not
exactly the same but it's like a similar
setup it's like a guy that can kind of
like see
ghosts and like sort of like these
demons or like these energy type things
and it's I think you would be it's kind
of like a horror comedy but and it's
like an action comedy I think you'd
really be into it like I watched it for
my show like for flickers of fear and I
really really dug it and like when I was
watching I was like oh my God this is
like kind of similar to The Frighteners
so you would probably like really like
it yeah oh man you're doing Jeffrey
Combs [ __ ] Asian Danvers [ __ ]
quotes because you are invading my
territorial bubble yeah yeah and he goes
the real freaky stuff like
yeah I love those I love it so much he's
like so awesome yeah because well I just
yes like I said this is why I love
horror and I love the horror Community
it's like somebody like that kind of
weird-ass [ __ ] it's like you can do that
and people just like love you forever
you you can you like next 20 30 years
you can show up at a horror convention
and everybody will just be like
like fawning all over you just because
of that one what was the name of Jeffrey
Combs character in in Star Trek
the Star Trek [ __ ] um uh where he
played uh the gem hedar
I don't want to call him a priestess but
he was kind of like a priestess and he
was the one that was [ __ ] making the
eggs and [ __ ] growing the gem had our
Warriors and giving them their rewards
and their sacraments they were giving
them like it was a it was a drug like
food that he was giving them
and they they grew to full size within a
year and they only lived like five or
six years before they died they were
just uh some kind of Clone Warriors that
he used they were but uh they were it
was like that whole race of aliens was
like a caste system
and he was one of the ones that made
sure that you brought these [ __ ] eggs
into [ __ ] so they gave birth and you
fed him I don't remember what his name
was but they were all the same he
himself was a clone
so he could get killed in in the episode
but Jeffrey Combs would still appear
because he was a clown there was [ __ ]
millions of them it was it was a great
concept
I just don't remember what the name of
that wouldn't that be wonderful if there
were millions of Jeffrey Combs there was
millions of them and they were alien
Jeffrey Combs there was in his alien
outfit yeah I just don't remember what
the name of it maybe you're just like
cloned a whole bunch of copies of like
the cool people and they just like let
the other people just like die they'd
kill one of them and then everybody
would be cool they killed one of them in
one episode then he showed back up
[ __ ] hey there's another one of me
yeah Camp Cisco would be like I thought
we killed you oh no no no that was
another one we've got lots of space we
got lots of us yeah yeah sorry I don't
remember what that guy was called though
yeah Zach says uh my taste in films are
stuff that's kind of already edgy
experimental and dark yeah I do I like
that yeah too and movies like that are
both hard to find and not mainstream
successful anymore that's it's why I
love 70s ones yeah I mean I have like
pretty broad tape like I'll watch pretty
much anything within reason
um you know but I mean obviously I have
certain proclivities I like I really
like horror movies I really like
experimental so the 70s is my favorite
decade but uh to be honest with you I've
seen a lot of really really really good
movies like in the last 10 15.
blairdo said way on I don't know if that
was his name Wayne I don't know if
there's his name uh he said he just
discovered Klaus know me and the number
oh yeah I was just gonna say yes know me
that's all I have for us man [ __ ]
yeah yeah he's good he died he died yeah
he died young died of AIDS of young but
it's so funny how well it's funny to me
how um yeah there's a great documentary
I think you mentioned it called Nomi
song yeah and
it's funny how like back in the day
you know after the explosion of punk and
then you had postpunk so everybody was
like doing like real experimental [ __ ]
and he comes out and essentially mixes
new wave and Opera yeah because he was
an opera singer
and people just had no [ __ ] and he also
was Ill real into like dada and like
surrealism and stuff and so like he'd
come out in like these [ __ ] crazy
outfits and stuff and so you would think
like like back then that like blew
people's [ __ ] minds like nowadays
people wouldn't care but it's like but
back then nobody had done that you know
what I mean but yeah I really like class
Naomi actually so if you haven't seen
Nomi song uh it's a really good doctor
speaking of which shutter just added a
two and a half hour documentary about
Gwar yeah and we watched it last night I
don't want to talk too much about it
because we might do it for the movie
retrospective on Sunday but I had a
really good time with it it was
surprisingly touching yeah it's good
it's a good it's a good documentary a
good story it's a surprise yeah
which is a [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
band I remember seeing flyers for Gore
when I was up in Detroit I thought you
had seen them live I saw them live I had
lots of times every time they came to
Orlando me and my brothers and our
friends would go see him yeah yeah we we
got covered with uh fake blood and other
fluids lots of times
lots of times uh but yeah that it's a
good time but I really liked they got I
mean other than the original members
that uh died which they get into but
they had like a lot of the original
members and it's just like I don't know
it's just like a fun punk rock DIY
story you know what I mean it was
actually like like I said it was like it
was weirdly like heartwarming
it was good I I liked it a lot yeah I
liked it a lot and like I said it was
like two and a half hours but it didn't
seem like it yeah it just kind of flew
by
uh they're talking about John Waters uh
film cereal mom which yeah I agree is
awesome although I haven't seen it in a
very long time I remember liking it a
lot Ricky Lake was in that when she was
younger Beretta said that [ __ ] he he
said that Jeffrey Combs also played a
Ferengi on Deep Space Nine yeah yeah
that's right I forgot about it they they
would they would call they would call
him in it they would call him in at any
moment to do some stuff he's always
hungry he was good
yeah he still is good he's doing a tour
a lot of live plays where he'll do
um
well he does that girl hey girl is he
still doing that evidently
I wouldn't mind seeing that if he was
ever burning he's a real good online
guest too
yeah we were we were watching to him on
like somebody's pocket yes one time we'd
like to have him on like we could
probably get him on and talk to him but
he drinks when he's online and [ __ ]
well we'd all drink and then we'd all
get in a big fight yeah
yeah he was talking to some guys that
had
props from the old movies that's right
and he was blown away
that uh somebody had the uh the
resonator
from Beyond yeah and he's talking to the
guy he goes yes I have the resonator the
rear view is you have the resonator
yeah I have the residential yeah and
he's yeah it's great it's right here
yeah Combs can't believe that the movies
he was in
our [ __ ] iconic he really can't but
see that's what's so cool about it you
have it and he's like yeah I have it
because if he was like something big I
have the resonator if he was some big
like [ __ ] Tom Cruise [ __ ]
yeah then like they well of course
that's awesome so of course everybody
has my stuff because everybody because
I'm the best person ever but it's just
kind of like the the cool thing about
and I know that like you know if you're
a working actor it probably kind of
sucks if you get sort of if you want to
use the word ghettoized into horror
um they're like man I'm never gonna get
like well known I'm never gonna like Get
Rich or anything like that which maybe
they don't but hopefully they have some
there's some consolation in the fact
that the horror Community if you're in a
really good horror movie people will
just love you forever I'll never forget
you and you can live on that [ __ ]
forever yeah you'd be signing [ __ ] at
the [ __ ] yeah like 20 years from now
you could be like [ __ ] 80 90 years
old and people be lining up yeah and
they'll have your face on the shirt and
[ __ ] like that and it's like I know well
because we were talking about this the
other day because remember the chat
and remember he got kind of like sick of
going to like Trekkie conventions and
stuff like that and I was like yeah but
I can see how that would get old but on
the other hand a lot of people who are
actors one never make it most actors
never make it two even if you do make it
a lot of them Never Land that iconic
role that everybody remembers I mean can
you imagine being the dude that was
Captain Kirk or you know or whatever it
was so it's like I know that it's like a
double-edged sword but oh you're
drinking my drink now
alcohol anyway
okay yeah you run everything I get it
well I mean you know I got the control
overall I'll make us all the drinks you
ever [ __ ] wanted okay it's not like
I'm stealing no I just thought it was
funny I thought you were I thought you
were just being like no stop listening
to what you're saying I'm listening to
what you're saying I just thought you
were being cheeky like I'm gonna drink
out of your drink because that's how I
roll I thought that I thought that was
getting into what you were saying and I
was just no but I'm just like but it's a
double-edged sword because it's like
if you're an actor that never really
made it or just kind of like you know
wallowed around and sort of like oh
you're that guy and like nobody ever
remembers your name and you never got to
be a star or anything but then on the
other hand if you had a role that was so
iconic that
you know you couldn't get another role
after that because it's like everyone
identified you with that that's bad too
but in a way I don't know I think that
you should probably appreciate that yeah
because most people would give their
[ __ ] back teeth
to be that famous yeah
um that woman from that woman from
Friday the 13th part one who was in all
those she was the one who played Jason's
mom Betsy Palmer Betsy Palmer was in all
these [ __ ] highfalutin movies back in
the 60s and 60s and 50s and [ __ ] she's
not remembered for any of that she made
her living towards the end you're
Jason's mom Jason's mom okay she went to
all the horror conventions and made a
living off of being Jason's mom and she
seemed mystified
stuff there I did all these [ __ ] high
level movies and nobody remembered yeah
that shit's all gone those fans are all
dead you know what I mean [ __ ] and
you know no it's all gone you were
Jason's mom from [ __ ] Friday the 13th
it's just be happy with that and she's
and she's uh
she's famous for that and she made a
living off of that and her in her final
years she didn't get it but she didn't
get it but she took the money she took
the money she didn't get it well she
came from a generation where horror was
[ __ ] schlock and yeah [ __ ] and
but those things are over I'm glad
that's those I mean the thing about it
and I remember I mean because it's only
been fairly recently like in the last
couple of decades that horror has
actually became been considered like uh
you know a genre worthy of something
other than scorn and derision yeah
because I kind of feel like prior to
that if you were into horror up until
probably like the 80s or 90s it was
ridiculed yeah people were just kind of
oh that crap that trash that you like
um you know what I mean it was that kind
of thing yeah yeah so I mean like their
movies none of them are real right um
you know what I mean so but they're fun
and they're entertaining so get that
stick out your butt and here's something
that you need to learn
people didn't change their minds
people died that's what made the
difference well that's the people sadly
that's usually what kind of has to
happen history that's what it goes back
to what I was saying before is that most
people when they get old they just die
they're well their views get very
ossified yeah I've really tried to like
not let that happen but it's like a lot
of people do kind of let that happen uh
that was the older Generations that are
like that though what happened yeah
uh our grandparents Generations were
very much in the Box they were like some
from another country
and things had to be a certain way they
never changed they died
and when they died they were replaced
with other people that didn't think that
they weren't that funny they weren't
like that and here's the thing that's
the way it's always been for [ __ ]
thousands of years well yeah it's a
cycle and like I said it's not even
you're not even the first person to have
pointed that out like I remember reading
that like a long time ago yeah people
don't usually change like when they get
older like people the old people with
the stupid old ideas like die off and
then die off yeah yeah well I was
thinking about why the world is round is
because the people that believed it was
flat died they didn't change their minds
they died thinking the world was flat
that's the example I'm giving you and
that is true that's
that's true the flat earthers although I
think that Flat Earth I think that was
um not as widespread as we've been led
to believe I don't think most people
believe that the world was I don't know
if it was most people but I don't think
it was as widespread as people I don't
think everybody believed that but um but
yeah no I was thinking about that
because remember I was talking earlier
about that girl that has the goth
Channel and she was talking about
and I was talking about like the talk
shows and stuff she I just remembered
that she was talking about having a job
interview in the early 90s I think it
was like the early 90s and she said she
looked like pretty normal like you know
nowadays you wouldn't like bat an eyelid
but the interviewer got all hung up
because she had blue nail polish and I
laughed because I was kind of like I
remember
back in those it's like funny to think
about now because every [ __ ] wears
what it's like I've seen like [ __ ]
Moms on YouTube wearing blue nail polish
back in the 80s and 90s you wore some
weird like you had black nail polish or
blue or something like that everyone
thought that was super weird you didn't
even have to like look that [ __ ]
weird otherwise yeah now Sly said I just
found out that the Rihanna Rihanna was
based upon HP Lovecraft yeah yeah it's a
Lovecraft yeah Herbert West reanimator
right that's the name of this it was
just based on
mentioned
mentioned him I don't think he he never
stated the story out of what had
happened he just in one of his stories
he mentioned Herbert West and his
ability to [ __ ] bring people back to
life from death
and that was about it well no there was
a story called Herbert West reanimator
oh wizard okay yeah all right I thought
that was about it it was the story
actually it was it might have been a
novella actually that's what I'm
thinking about right probably not
because I haven't read everything from
HP love it's not it's very loose it's
very Loosely based I mean the character
is kind of similar but not exactly the
same it's pretty loose because I only I
am the only Lovecraft story I I read
I only read two of them call the Cthulhu
which I don't think was a full-size book
I remember correct well he didn't really
write I mean I think I think the only
novel novel he wrote was uh in the
mountains of Madness I read that one
most of his stuff was like Novella
lengths or short stories that was his
professional I thought I thought I
thought reanimator was just mentioned in
another story no there was a story
called Herbert West or animator okay
yeah I didn't know that yeah I have a
whole book back there how many pages are
we talking oh I don't know I'd have to
look I don't I don't know not long
though huh
it was longer than some of his other
stuff because he had a tendency to like
Roy bull because he wrote for weird
Tales a lot so you know he wrote like
pretty short stories only a couple pages
but Herbert West reanimator I kind of I
remember was like kind of longer all
right it was a bit now they do have a
couple of other like fan made movies
that are pretty good
um color out of space
which came out recently yeah with
Nicolas Cage with Nick Cave is is not
Nick Cave Nicholas Cage it's two
completely different those two two
completely see this [ __ ] [ __ ] with
me okay what I'm correcting you Nicholas
Cage I bet drink I'm technically correct
with this which is the best kind of
correct
yeah uh trying to think of another
another uh Lovecraft movie
Dagon Dagon which was actually based on
uhmuth right horror from ismath yeah or
whatever but yeah it's not well he did
write a story called Dagon but the movie
is not an adaptation of Dagon yeah it's
based on
the yeah what you said or out of in
Smith or whatever that is what story is
about I think is what it's called now
you're like distracting me because I'm
just say I'm [ __ ] you yeah yeah Dagon
is the best Lovecraft adaptation with
the wrong title yeah yeah if you all
want to see a good Lovecraft movie see
Dagon I got it on Blu-ray I mean to be
honest I kind of feel like I really
liked Dagon well to me
I mean having read Lovecraft Dagon to me
felt the most like a year like a
Lovecraft story yeah because I feel like
a lot of Lovecraft adaptations as much
as I like them
don't seem like wanna like don't have
the same Vibe as his stories to me and
they got a character in there that
support you look a shadow over and smoke
shadow of her instrument that's that's
right that's what I mean you can't
confuse me yeah because I kept thinking
horror at Red Hook I'm like what are you
talking about
Dagon is real similar to Shadow over in
Smith well it is Shadow over it yeah
okay but like I said he has a story
called Dagon yeah but this movie is not
an adaptation It's actually an
adaptation of Shadows with a little bit
of Dagon in there one of the main the
main character in it when you look at
the dude you know that it's supposed to
be [ __ ] my boy [ __ ] uh uh uh of
Jeffrey Combs but Jeffrey Combs would
have been a little bit too old
because he was supposed to be a kid in
college yeah he's supposed to be like
college supposed to be in college so at
Miss katame yeah from miskatonic
University and and [ __ ] he would have
been [ __ ] he would have been a little
bit too old so they cast another guy
who's a lot like him you know
uh but the movie is [ __ ] awesome a
lot of cool [ __ ] happens some scenes got
cut
where they were cutting that Spanish got
that the Spanish guy cutting them in
half yeah I've never cutting him up or
they were skinning them actually didn't
they skin his face off he's getting this
whole body it's still pretty it's still
pretty gruesome yeah it's still pretty
gruesome yeah the old drunk guy yeah the
old drunk guy so I don't know I just
really did like a guy Sly go stream
Dagon you'll like it you'll like it it's
good moving and they got a cute Spanish
chick in there in a wheelchair I still
want to do that for a Halloween costume
she's just a little [ __ ] Spanish
chick in the wheel I want it like the
gold crown and the tentacles right and
everything and she tries to throw that'd
be so bad she tries to throw the
poonanny Nanny on a dude and it turns
out she's nothing Botanicals
yeah she's dig on surprise
yeah that's like seriously that's my
dream Halloween costume from the second
I saw that movie like several years ago
I was like oh my God I have to do that
one year but I don't know it's just like
I want to do it but if I do it I have to
do it right and it's just kind of like
that's gonna be super expensive because
she has like a really
specific looking
Crown uh it's gold and it's kind of like
this branchy kind of I don't know like
it's a crown and she has this cool
outfit and she's in a wheelchair and um
because I'm assuming she can't walk
because she has tentacles so yeah so she
has tentacles and I was like man how
badass would that be I was like if we're
gonna go to like a horror convention one
year or something like that for
Halloween I totally want to do that but
like I said I need to like spend the
money to do it right
because
it has to look
correct you know I'm very into that when
I do Halloween costumes it has to
actually look
like the actual thing even though
probably I don't know if I went to a
horror convention I kind of feel like
people would know what it was but if I
went anywhere else people were like what
the [ __ ] are you supposed to be
you know I'm kind of used to that
whatever
uh Zach says um
I've seen a lot of women in their 60s
wearing black nail polish these days it
looks really good on them I think
Isabella pair wears black nail black
nail polish a lot too yeah oh man Isabel
Uber I love her but um yeah and it's
it's funny to think about now and I had
forgotten about it until she mentioned
it and she's like look I looked like
pretty normal
um you know she's like I maybe had black
clothes on but I look like gothy or
anything I just had like regular clothes
and the fact that she had blue nail
polish and this job interviewer was like
real like hung up about it like well you
have to you're gonna have to change that
if you want to work here blah blah and I
was like it's like and it's crazy to
think about that now but I remember when
[ __ ] was like that I remember when [ __ ]
was like that because when I was a
teenager
and in my 20s yeah you absolutely if you
were blue nail polish
to a job interview or something like
that people would be like what they
would think that was the weirdest thing
ever which is bizarre because it's like
why is blue nail polish any weirder than
red nail polish
you could have worn red nail polish and
nobody would have battered an eye but
you wear blue and suddenly that's
strange I don't get it I didn't get it
back then but yeah they were weird
that's what I mean it's like that's it
didn't make any sense to me and like I'm
so glad that like the rest of the world
like caught up and is like what the [ __ ]
they're just colors like just it's
[ __ ] how long we've been streaming
two hours and 51. okay it's almost about
time you wanna shut it down well not we
want you just want to run with that no I
want another drink if you want to go for
a win another half hour hour I don't
know I'm still having a good time aren't
you
at least you settled down some
DJ Maniac said the worst part would have
to be explaining that costume to
everyone I know and that's the only
thing that's the only thing because I
always have like these
I was on my Halloween fantasies
everyone's like oh my God this would be
the best costume ever I was like my my
aspirational costumes are that like from
Dagon and
um what's her face from uh Flash Gordon
what's her name General like kala that's
her name right and I can and I was gonna
make that and I even like that year I
even like looked into it it's like how
much would it cost to like make this
because I was gonna make it and she has
like this really elaborate headpiece
with all these like shiny beads and all
this other kind of stuff I'm like oh
that'd be badass I'm gonna make that and
like by the time I got myself like oh my
God this is gonna cost like a thousand
dollars I'm like I don't have a thousand
dollars but um but you know
and yeah that's the thing and
I don't know I have this weird thing
where it's just kind of like I don't
like
to wear store-bought Halloween costumes
but if I'm on a dress like something
from a movie or something like that I
want it to be something that like not
everybody does too I really really don't
like dressing like but it's again it's
like a double-edged sword because it's
like I don't want a Halloween costume
that everyone's like oh you're Pennywise
you know what I mean like everyone said
oh you're you know whatever the [ __ ]
it's like you know what I mean I don't
want to be
something that everybody knows what it
is immediately I kind of want to be a
costume where you're gonna have that one
person come up and go holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
and they know exactly what you are and
everyone else is just kind of like what
the [ __ ] are you supposed to be
I don't know it's a curse I don't know
what it is
[Laughter]
uh
Zach says I just Googled Isabella pair
how can a woman who's nearly 70 be that
sexy still I don't know to be honest
like I think she is actually one of the
sexiest women on earth I I always
thought which one who Isabella pair
which who's that she's a French actress
I don't know she's old now well yeah I
saw like a bunch of stuff like for old
stuff like back in the day and
I don't know there's just something
about her that's like really sexy to me
I don't know what it is so you'd hit
oh yeah she did yeah
Hugo says underwater is lovecraftian I
think oh it's yeah that's definitely
Lovecraft I haven't seen it man
everybody yeah you have you've seen
underwater
underwater
the water
the one with Chris oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah I was thinking about the one with
the with the girl who the water creature
was trying to screw what was the name of
that one
underwater was good real looking lovely
I was gonna say you've talked about that
yeah yeah like that is absolutely well
that that had straight up like Cthulhu
at the end pretty but they didn't call
it that but that's what it was the one
what was the one with the girl who she
trying to have sex with the damn water
creature
the shape of water shape of water I
thought I saw it I didn't see that one I
thought Guillermo del Toro yeah that's
what I thought you were talking about
yeah underwater was [ __ ] great I
loved it guiller del Toro's shape of
water I actually really liked it I don't
know if you'd like it it's not a horror
movie it's more well is it it's kind of
like an updated Creature from the Black
Lagoon so it's like has a little bit of
horror element to it but it's mostly
like a weird like romance
and yeah sort of but I don't know I
really dug it I really dug it but I
don't know if you'd like it or not maybe
you would it's hard to say like I said
it's essentially like Creature from the
Black Lagoon it's like if Creature from
the Black Lagoon but the chick was like
into the fish man Psy says he's going to
check out Dagon yeah you're gonna like
Dagon I had to order a special Blu-ray
release it's hard to get well yeah well
they made it in Spain they made it in
Spain it's in English and it was it was
recorded in English but it was made in
Spain
and it was it had a lot of the same
people that did reanimate her if I
remember correct well even like some of
the later reanimator movies I think they
made that and then in Spain as well you
like it you'll like it I mean I've heard
mixed reviews like some people really
really like it and some people are like
meh but I don't know day gone to be
to me like like I said I kind of feel
like a lot of the best lovecraftian
movies like the thing or the void or
something like that are not really based
on a Lovecraft story but are just like
in the spirit of that yeah like in the
Lovecraft Universe yeah but Dagon I
think was one of the best Straight
adaptations of a Lovecraft story that
I've seen and I think other than the
ones that the Lovecraft Appreciation
Society does like but cool but their
[ __ ] they actually make it look like an
old silent movie like it like it came
out at the time that the story came out
which I actually really appreciate that
yeah and those are like actually they're
good too those are actually cool they
did a good version of Cthulhu and it's
like why watching King Kong claymation
yeah they made it all like look like a
silent movie which like I said I really
admire that like I like when they just
they're like we don't give a [ __ ] if
like a million people like watch this or
we make like a kind of money we just
want to make it like this and this is
how we want to make it and
Whoever likes it'll like it but Dagon I
think I paid 40 bucks for Dagon
I uh
and that was a a pre-order it came with
a [ __ ] jacket I think it was a steel
book and everything one for my version
of Dagon the Blu-ray version
it and it was it was a special release
it's good but I think you can stream it
it's probably on Amazon
yeah it seemed like for a while it was
like hard to get hold of yeah but
I don't know we'll see if you liked
reanimate or Sly you'll you'll instantly
just click right into [ __ ] Dagon
it's it's so real similar I know this is
gonna be weird to say but it smells like
a Lovecraft yeah it's it's very very
damp yeah you'll know and it's very
fishy yeah and I was like this is what I
pictured in my head when I was reading
Lovecraft the difference is is that is
that in reanimator most of the shits
happening indoors
and Dagon a lot of it's happening
outside on an island in a city on an
island or a town on an island and
they've all been turned into fish people
yeah they're all like kind of pale and
you have like big Popeyes yeah yeah they
made that deal with dagar okay worth it
for gold and fish from the sea to become
and that will make sense after you see
it gold and fish from the sea
[Laughter]
they [ __ ] made a deal with Dagon okay
that if they worshiped they throw down
the old gods and worship Dagon that
they'll get free gold and free fish from
the sea
but they change into fish people that's
okay it's part yeah it's pretty good
yeah
and then they return to the ocean to be
with Daga
yeah that's okay yeah you can Dagon
guarantee I won't get eaten by a shark
Dagon can guarantee okay Dad [ __ ] you
will not be I'm down sure yeah where you
at [ __ ] that's right it's not out of
the ocean I'll take that bet
[Music]
that was cthulhu's God as far as I know
yeah yeah I'm trying to think of like
some other God what were some other like
straight adaptations of Lovecraft
stories that were good
I mean Colorado space was good yeah
pretty good it wasn't great but it was
Mandy but it was good well yeah but
Mandy wasn't a love grabs at it yeah but
yeah I don't know what I'm saying but
for a Lovecraft adaptation it was really
good for some reason like I don't know
it's kind of like
Lovecraft adaptations that a lot of them
really don't work on the big screen I
guess it's just like the nature of the
Beast because lovecraftian stuff is by
its nature
supposed to be inexplicable and like you
know way bigger than your experience
it's so it's much better when you read
it because you can like imagine it if
you have to like sort of confine it by
putting it on like you know making a
visual of it yeah then it's not gonna
yeah you've not it's not gonna be as
effective so I think that you're really
kind of shooting yourself in the dick
from the yeah
um lovecraft's writing was all about
feeling any mode yeah and description
well an implication and it was like just
a a hint of like something much larger
and you were just like seeing some big
and so it was all like this implication
of this much larger thing that was going
on and I don't think that translates all
that well to the screen so I think that
that's kind of like I said I heard
Annihilation was based upon it is I mean
Loosely it's not based on a Lovecraft
story but it's definitely based on the
Lovecraft idea because I don't know if
you know but even when Lovecraft was
alive
back in the 30s like the 20s and 30s he
had a whole
circle of other writers who wrote In His
Universe like so they have like extended
Universe of like August erlith and
people like that August duralith
actually like published a lot of his
stuff like after he died because he died
fairly young so ever since he was around
and then like shortly after he died
there's been a whole other contingent of
writers that wrote in the lovecraftian
universe and that continues up to this
day I mean I think every year there's a
new horror Anthology that comes out
that's like lovecrafty and horror like
other people writing in that universe so
it's that's not a new thing like the
extended universe so people like are
coming up with their own like offshoots
of it because it's just such a vast
mythology you can do so much with it you
have some even Stephen King wrote in
that
recently there have been some young
people [ __ ]
throwing their ass up in the air like oh
don't read him he's racist no read him
he was racist read him he was racist big
time yeah he was racist against white
people he was racist even for the time
even for the time okay [ __ ] he was an
anglo-american and he didn't like Irish
people or Irish Americans he was
extremely into xenophobia if you weren't
like him then [ __ ] man he had problems
whoo
well because of that that's what made
his horror so good if he wasn't
xenophobic or racist because he was
afraid of eggs everybody everybody right
and that's what made his horror so good
he was a man filled with fear of fear
yeah uh but as he got older he changed
yeah he did chill out a little he
chilled out about it he would live he
was a very shy person very sheltered
sheltered and he didn't know much about
the outside world
and that helped him right [ __ ] real
creepy horror
uh I don't know what had if he'd become
kind of more open to other people I
don't know if his horror would have been
as good he didn't Maybe
he might have I don't well that's what I
mean I was kind of thinking about that
because I was like well I don't know if
he would have gone in a completely
different direction or yeah it might
have become I mean the thing about it
was that he
sometimes I think in his particular case
I don't think this is true of everybody
but I think in his particular case the
reason that he's he resonated so much
and that people still remember his [ __ ]
nowadays was because of his isolation
and his he didn't really he because he
grew up so sheltered sheltered and stuff
like that he didn't really have a lot of
outside experiences so a lot of his
you know experiences were internal like
it was all like imaginations his fantasy
no fears and that was his very singular
Vision that he came up with so had he
just been like a regular ass person that
just had regular-ass friends yeah it was
regular-ass [ __ ] you know he might not
have come up with like the crazy ass
[ __ ] that he came up with because that
takes somebody that usually not always
um you know some completely normal
well-adjusted people have come up with
some crazy [ __ ] too but I think that
really helped that he was so messed up
yeah well part of it has to do with his
concept of God okay
in the time that he lived God was a
Christian God in the area that he was in
but he rebelled against that
his version of God was an uncaring God
or a God that didn't know about you yeah
it was just like indifferent right and
if the God if that God did know about
you it would hate you all right which
that made his stories even better
okay because that's a pretty horrifying
concept I mean it's less horrifying
nowadays but it was a nice day in those
days that was a very horrifying concert
yeah to think that there were Gods but
they they hated they either hated you or
they did not give a single [ __ ] about
you you were just like ants to them
right and so that was like a really
scary thing that whole idea was alien
for lovecraft's time and alien and
[ __ ] Lovecraft wrote this [ __ ] and he
ended up getting a fan base
of people that that resonated with them
and other writers yeah that immediately
recognized oh my God this is like this
is something different yeah maybe God
maybe the gods do hate us or don't care
about it I mean it's not even had he
even had groupies
stalking him yeah that he was terrified
of him he was like oh [ __ ] because they
thought what Lovecraft was writing was
real
yeah this is like I was like no these
are my nightmares and my fantasies
but he had a [ __ ] Cult of followers
out in the shadows that thought he was
channeling reality as if he were an
oracle
or HP Lovecraft or [ __ ] or L Ron
Hubbard that he's the source in in
[ __ ] Scientology that he knows what's
true so do you you had people I was
crazy [ __ ] that thought was
real
and that [ __ ] Cthulhu was real
and we're looking looking for Lovecraft
to meet him
to to because that [ __ ] yeah
to merge with the source and [ __ ]
tell us all about the goat with a
thousand young yeah tell us all about
this [ __ ]
and that scared the [ __ ] out of [ __ ]
Lovecraft he's like oh [ __ ] he ran it
well like I said everything scared the
[ __ ] out of the place to be fair yeah
but that's why that was so good it was
another thing because he was afraid of
literally everything yeah he was like a
shut-in yeah
who from a real uptight family from a
very very uptight family he didn't have
any normal friends he did he was very
very sickly he was always he was a
homebody not real good looking he was
kind of a homely kind of guy but I would
say he wasn't bad looking I don't think
yeah he was kind of he looked like some
[ __ ] that she should be on the
money
he should be like on a five dollar bill
or a thirty dollar bill or something you
know I think well he's one of those
[ __ ] okay
nowadays if somebody that came out that
looked like H.P Lovecraft and they would
be no this is just like a hypothetical
situation yeah and they came out and
they were just kind of like oh girls
don't like me because I because because
I'm not because I look like this but I'm
like but the thing about that though is
that I don't think it's because he
looked like that I think it's because
the second you started talking to him
you're like oh my God this dude is a
racist weirdo yeah I think it was that
because I think he was a perfectly like
decent looking dude I thought he was
just normal looking he ended up he ended
up hooking up with a Jewish chick that
[ __ ] loved his work Sonia green her
name was she was also a writer yeah and
uh that kind of softened him up because
she started introducing him to other
people and getting him plus she made him
move to New York City for a while
because that's where because and he
freaked out at first he's like oh my God
immigrants yeah yeah other people yeah
he was like that like I said go read
horror at Red Hook and the immigrants
he's talking about Italians
Italians and [ __ ] lithuanians yeah
anybody who wasn't yeah he was very
English he was very much crazy but
here's the thing people also said based
on what I remember is that
is that once he started talking to you
if he lied to you then a lot of that
[ __ ] [ __ ] fell away it was in his
imagination
he wasn't a bad person he was just yeah
like I said I don't really think he was
very very sheltered yeah I don't really
think he had a lot of experiences
outside of his own family like I think
he was very coddled he didn't really
have a lot of outside experiences he
didn't meet a lot of people that were
different to him right so he didn't
really have a a very wide world we have
experience he didn't have experience so
it's like everything like caused him
anxiety yeah you know what I mean so
anybody that's like oh my God they're
like a shade darker than me oh dear like
what do we have an accent like yeah oh
my God like what what's this is like a
subhuman it was just kind of like and he
was like oh my God where's my fainting
couch it was like that kind of thing and
I think a lot of that was due to his
upbringing because like I said yeah like
a lot of people were racist back then
but even by those days standards yeah he
still kind of stood out yeah he still
stood out yeah so you know what I mean
like I said read some of his fiction
you'll see it like I mean I've read a
lot of fiction from not only his era but
like older than that like late 19th
century he vilifies and demonized
everyone everybody and foreign
yeah just like you're a [ __ ] monster
and I'm gonna say that like you know
I've read a lot of um because I read a
lot of horror fiction I like a lot of
horror fiction for like the late 19th
century stuff like that like old ghost
stories and stuff and in those sometimes
like you'll be reading them it's a
normal ass ghost story or whatever and
then there's like some very casual
racism and I'm just like okay we're
going we're going down that way but it's
just kind of like okay well that's kind
of like it's not good but that was like
how it was at the time but so I'm kind
of used to that but even by those
standards he was [ __ ] bad yeah like
some of the [ __ ] he that he wrote If you
read the story by like through today's
eyes yeah you you obviously know what
he's talking yeah but here's the thing I
read that I remember reading that stuff
and instantly recognizing it as somebody
who didn't know all right so somebody
who's imagining this is a white dude
like you said very sheltered and coddled
he doesn't know any of these people no
he he's
heating this up sure okay that so I
never I always thought it was just kind
of humorous yeah but I mean like yeah
you don't forget
that's not that's not how it actually is
so I always laugh at that [ __ ] and if
you're [ __ ] not okay first of all
first of all I'm [ __ ] I would be
considered [ __ ] irish-american most
because most of my [ __ ] Bloodlines
would be Irish and Scottish and German
okay not a lot of English really or
anglo-american probably Irish German
Scottish mostly from the south he
wouldn't have liked me
he would have thought that I was a sub
human
okay
he was Anglo
it had to be English this was some [ __ ]
up in Massachusetts back in his day like
I said he had a he was he was very
narrow band yeah it's just like he was
very he was racist against white people
yeah against other way people other
white people which some people like
other white people were back then like I
said yeah you know you had Irish come
over here and everybody
oh my God Irish or Italians which like I
said nowadays ever be like uh yeah
they're just regular ass white people
but back then not so much right but this
is but he was like that like times a
hundred but his
his opinions did not come from informed
experience it was a clear from not
knowing yes you know it's uh
I always just thought it was [ __ ]
funny but I [ __ ] love what he wrote I
loved [ __ ] yeah in the Mounds of
Madness that needs to be made in the
movie and evidently Guillermo del Toro
was gonna he's been trying like for
years in the mountains if it was done
right would be alien or beat the thing
any day if you did that [ __ ] the right
way because [ __ ] that was a great
movie
or that was a great book I mean [ __ ]
and if you did it right you didn't pick
a great movie but I think you'd have to
do it in the past it couldn't be normal
it couldn't be
normal times it would have to be the
1900s
yeah see I don't think like any like all
the best love it like Dagon is set in
present day but that and that works well
90s sort of yeah well I mean present day
like when it came more or less
but I kind of feel like most of the best
Lovecraft adaptations that I've seen
particularly the ones that Lovecraft
Appreciation Society have done
have been set at the time that the
stories were set and I think that that's
kind of what you have to do because
there is really something about
I don't I don't know I just don't think
you can modernize it you can modernize
the Universe
um because I have seen other modern
lovecraftian movies like said in the
lovecrafting universe that were very
good but if you're gonna adapt one of
the stories I think you have to like set
it at the time period it's not going to
be the same otherwise yeah dust memory
says the beach house is totally
underrated lovecraftian horror I
actually saw that that was actually
really really good and I wasn't
expecting it to be lovecraftian so that
was like a pleasant surprise yeah uh
blurred a dude said is the thing
lovecraftian yes yes yes yes yes the the
the the thing is actually a shag off
from in the mountains of Madness if you
read that book a shag off was a an alien
creature that the great old ones had
enslaved it was a Mindless amoeba that
could be anything they needed it to be
and they used it as a construction
creature and one day it got a hold of a
brain it absorbed an old one and and and
and had the data to make a brain and
then once it had a brain it shared it
with all the other the other shag off
and they became intelligent and then
they rose up and overthrew the great old
ones and that was
that's how the great old ones [ __ ] up
in the North Pole that's how they were
killed the Shag off did it in other
words the things from the from the thing
yeah that's what I'm saying that's why
I'm saying that like I think a lot of
the best Lovecraft at it like
lovecraftian movies have not been
adaptations of his stories but rather
things that it like just took
inspiration yeah from his stories
um you know but like I said I kind of
feel like if you're gonna do an
adaptation of a story you kind of have
to do it like old school because I think
that'd be like better Zach says I like
to think Lovecraft is on the autism
spectrum yeah he probably was I mean if
anybody from the past and I don't really
like to mentally diagnose like people
from the past it's a different world
back then it's hard um but from
everything that I've read about
Lovecraft uh yeah yeah I think
definitely nowadays if he was around
nowadays that would uh that would
actually apply Danny Rowling said he
kind of had a Mr Potato Head looking
face he did he did he did but he wasn't
but see like I said I kind of had that
[ __ ] Slimer mouth where he didn't
have much of a lip so he looked like he
was kind of he didn't have much of an
upper lip but like I said that's okay
yeah he wasn't like I said you see
pictures of him he's funny looking but
he's not
ugly yeah and even if he was ugly
if he was cool no one would care right I
don't think he was a bad looking dude I
don't think he was about I don't think
he was uncool I just think that he was
[ __ ] he was just weird he was
probably weird and off-putting well
because he wasn't real I think he wasn't
real socially Adept no I think was the
problem and he was kind of like probably
on the autism spectrum a little bit
probably and it and that makes things
harder because you're just kind of like
well even if you look Okay and like I
said he looked okay he looked normal and
[ __ ] but if you don't really have like a
lot of um you know experience with
people or you're not real socially adapt
then you might come off as like weird
and that's probably like off-putting to
a lot of people and then that's gonna
reinforce oh [ __ ] something's wrong with
me because they're not responding the
way that I think they ought to be
responding and then that's gonna make
you like go more into yourself and it's
just like a whole like cycle slide
mentions it he says yeah those narrow
band people they're just kind of funny
or yeah I don't take them seriously
because they don't have any power over
you they can't do anything to you
they're just [ __ ] kinda I don't want
to call them dumb they just some they
have some intelligent people that just
don't have enough experience or
knowledge or empathy they don't know how
other people live uh or they've been
told a bunch of [ __ ] so when they were
young that's kind of set them up for
failure and they they believe things
that are quaint
they're not true they think they're true
but they but then that same dude could
come up with some [ __ ] pretty
interesting [ __ ]
and and Lovecraft was like that yeah he
was like that back in his day back in
his day people thought he were strange
so yeah so that should tell you so that
should tell you because back then
everybody was kind of funny yeah
they had some dumbass surprise back then
so no read his [ __ ] he's [ __ ] he's a
genius he's a great writer
he's weird
he has a bunch of
idiosyncrasies even by his by those days
standards
but he's creating some [ __ ] very cool
art
and it resonated with people back in the
day particularly other writers like I
said because a lot of them immediately
picked up on it and started writing in
that same and I don't you know and I can
empathize with him I'm not agreeing
empathy is not the same as agreeing I
can empathize with what he's saying I
don't agree with you saying but I can
see it through his eyes that and that's
that's what the job of a writer is is to
is to show you another world
and and he was good at that well he
totally did that and he was and he was
he was punk rock and [ __ ] cyberpunk
and all that [ __ ] long before that [ __ ]
existed he could he'd come up with some
weird ass [ __ ] it was like alien or
alien 2 and [ __ ] predator and [ __ ]
everything else he was coming up with
some [ __ ] cool [ __ ] back in the early
can you imagine like I think HP
Lovecraft if you could somehow go back
in a time machine and bring him to the
modern day and show him how his rating
has influenced I mean they're look at
all those lovecraftian [ __ ] that said
there's video games and board games
I don't we'll see the thing about it
though is that I don't really know
he's one of those people where I'm not
really sure how he would be like well of
course
but I think he would be like well of
course but I don't think he would
because
he's also kind of like self-loathing too
I think I don't know I think he would be
well of course it was cool what I did
but I think he would be blown away by
the present day
I don't think he would like it I think
he would like crawl under the bed like
Pookie does when it's like outside it
depends that's not what time you got him
that's what I'm saying depends on what
time and his development you got it this
is married I could probably talk sense
to him maybe I take him to the club and
[ __ ] he'd probably have a good time I
don't know I I kind of have a feeling
he'd probably just stand there in the
corner with his arms like that well he
would but he's like oh well oh man but
you could probably we should get him
drunk and then yeah you could probably
he might be super fun when he's drunk
well part of part of that thing that
thing that you're talking about is the
fear of other people condemning you and
because he's now in the future nobody's
going to condemn him so he can now do
what he wants to do you know what I mean
and everyone's just like yeah I suppose
so yeah
so I think which to me that's a much
better way to be just leave everybody
alone a lot of those let them do their
thing a lot of the dudes a lot of those
dudes from the 1800s
in the first half of the 1900s were were
a product of pure peer pressure
that was that was a lot of it
they're afraid of getting canceled
it might well
that's the thing and I kind of feel like
this is why I would never ever even if I
invented a time machine which I'm way
too busy to do by the way
even if I did that I really don't think
that I would ever want to go back to any
other time periods like I don't
I don't know man like even the time that
I grew up like in the 70s and 80s man
like yeah there was some cool [ __ ] about
back then but it's like there was so
much like shitty [ __ ] that it's like I'm
not going back there [ __ ] that no people
in the future would think that about our
time well I know that but it's like I
know that but it's just kind of like I
don't know I kind of feel like see some
people it's like oh I want to go back to
the episode like why the [ __ ] would you
want to do that I'm confident I could go
back to the 20s and I'd run that [ __ ]
I'd probably have a lot of fun I don't
know I don't want to go back to before
air depends on where you want to go yeah
and the air conditioning no thanks no
thanks I lived before the internet we
didn't know any better
um but now that we have it I'm just like
yeah no I don't think I want to go back
to a time before that that would like
suck a lot
um somebody said something I wanted to
uh
DJ Maniac said Lovecraft wasn't a great
writer to begin with yeah that's you
know that's true who said that Maniac he
used a lot of adjectives well he was
trying to be like the classic writers
that he grew up with he's trying he's
trying to be like some [ __ ]
Dracula well he was real into who's that
uh he was real into like Lord Duncan he
wasn't yeah I kind of feel like so yeah
he's trying to write books from
two or three generations before his time
yeah
but one thing I was going to say was
that this is um an idle thought that I
have every now and then
if I could go back in time and bring
some famous person like to the modern
day how do I think they would react
and I have thought about doing that with
HP Lovecraft but I don't think that
would go very well other people that
I've thought about I was like What if I
went back in time and brought Charles
Darwin yeah to nowaday he'd probably be
cool I feel like he would probably be
cool like everything I've read about him
like I've read a lot of his stuff and he
seems like he'd be like oh all right HP
Lovecraft not so much I kind of feel
like he would just like stand there and
be like oh my God we're saying that
Lovecraft was a great writer we're not
talking about the writing per se we're
talking about the ideas that he came up
his rating was very um yeah we're
talking about the ideas it's very
overwrought it's very purple by today's
standard because his motherfucker's
wordy as [ __ ] but that's okay I mean to
be honest I like adjectives too he
tended to use a lot of the same ones uh
he used Eldridge a lot squamous yeah you
know what I mean but he used like a lot
of the same adjectives but that's okay
that's okay
um I don't know like like I said you
know I can only aspire to a hundred
years from now yeah my [ __ ] writing
being remembered he's trying to sound
like Bram Stroker and he's trying to
sound like [ __ ] he said Bram stroker
that's the poor stroker yeah
stroker I'm [ __ ] drunk please please
tell me that there's a porn star called
brand stroker that dresses like a
vampire yeah it'd be awesome please tell
me that that exists and if it doesn't it
should
if it doesn't it should Bram stroker
stars in
[Laughter]
no I'm just I'm going off on a whole
thing I'm just like oh my God I just
thought of like a whole like other
tangent yeah this is how my brain worked
I just thought of like a whole other
tangent of a sub-genre of porn
where you were doing like vampire porn
and they all star
Bram Striker so I'm trying to like think
of like vampire themed like porn names
like like names of like porno movies
it's all about HG Wells was ahead of his
time yeah HG Wells HG Wells another one
I thought I think that was mostly
because of Time After Time uh R.I.P
David we wrote a bunch of stuff
um HG Wells if you don't know time after
time which came out in 1979 is about H.G
Wells played by uh Malcolm McDowell who
comes to the Future in that case 1979
because that's when the uh movie was
made and he's plays HG Wells I invented
a time machine but oh actually I did
invent a time machine it actually works
Jack the Ripper escapes to the future or
1979 in the time machine and then HG
Wells has to get in the time machine and
come to
1979 to stop Jack thrower from killing
people so that's how that movie goes so
HG Wells was another one that I thought
about and I think HG Wells would
probably also be cool I kind of feel
like anybody that was a scientist or a
Sci-Fi writer
they might have a few weeks of like
be weirded out like because I mean
if you know it
it's hard to like imagine how much
progress has been made like in a very
short time unless you kind of like go
back and think about it so
but I do kind of feel like people that
are that were scientists back in the day
people that were sci-fi writers back in
the day they're probably like better
prepared if you brought them just like
willing to say hey I'm coming back in a
time machine and it's like hey I'm gonna
take you to the Future come on let's go
and you get here to 2022. I think most
of them they they would probably need a
couple weeks to like acclimate
which is you know fair enough that's
understandable but I feel like most of
them would probably be like after a
while to be like all right I dig it it's
you know this happened and that happened
Okay and like you'd have to catch them
up on stuff and but I think they'd deal
with it
other people I don't know I kind of like
feel about them
and like I said I thought about it
mostly with like scientists and stuff
because I'm into that kind of stuff but
HP Lovecraft I didn't think about him
and I was just kind of like what would
happen
maybe some maybe I should write a story
about that has anybody wrote a story
about that somebody going back in time
and bringing HP Lovecraft to like the
modern day like when he flip out he
probably would flip out
I don't know like after a while he might
chill out though somebody might give him
some weed and he might I don't know
he might eventually like [ __ ] take
the stick out his ass and like I don't
know I just figured he just seemed very
of his time and he seemed very
rigid and it wasn't his fault
necessarily I think it was kind of like
just the you know the culture of the way
he was brought up
but
I don't know man I kind of feel like it
might take a while for you might have to
like get him super drunk or super high
who's that HP Lovecraft for him to be
super fun well no I was what I was
saying was that I think that people that
wrote sci-fi like AC Wells are people
that were scientists like Charles Darwin
it would probably be like a lot easier
to acclimate them to modern day to
modern day than somebody else
because they're already predisposed to
think toward the future you know what I
mean so maybe they wouldn't think it was
like oh I already thought of something
like that and you have something like
that now like you know what I mean like
I the framework would be wider so I kind
of feel like that would maybe I don't
know that's something that I like think
about a lot Charles Darwin I don't know
for some reason I just thought it would
be really interesting to like bring
Charleston modern day I don't know why I
thought of that I guess because I read a
lot of his stuff
um
yeah and H like I said H.G Wells was
another one I thought of but I think it
was because that movie time after time
because that was about h2o's right even
though it was Malcolm McDowell
most writers that also have to have that
on Blu-ray by the way
we ought to I know okay because we don't
have it God damn it I love it that's a
good movie oh I haven't seen that in a
long time I love that movie when's the
last time we saw that movie I don't know
well I've seen it so many times that I
have it memorized yeah but
I don't know if you've seen it as many
times as I oh man I used to see that
[ __ ] on HBO [ __ ] all the goddamn time
when it was [ __ ] kind of new yeah
because it was on every five [ __ ]
minutes well and it wasn't just HBO it
was on all the pay channels like if he's
just like oh I'm on HBO and hey Time
After Time is on you click over to
Cinemax okay Time After Time is on over
here
streaming three hours and 28 minutes
okay it's about time Zach says I keep
thinking it'd be hilarious to take Henry
VIII to modern day and see what happens
it depends on what time in his life I
mean [ __ ] see I don't know see I
don't know how well yeah like I said I
kind of feel like his life he was [ __ ]
up but there's people that you can bring
to this is why I think this question is
interesting
because I think that people like I said
sci-fi writers scientists stuff like
that they're already predisposed to
think in terms of like progress or think
ahead
they already are more open-minded maybe
it's like they have a wider band if you
want to say that they're not their
narrowband so I kind of feel like it'd
be easier to acclimate them they might
be like they might be like freaked out
and like what the [ __ ] oh my God I
didn't expect this to happen or that to
happen or whatever but they would get
used to it quicker
people that were more into like somebody
that was maybe a monarch that was very
uh you know kind of verse more in a
hierarchical kind of situation where
money's coming from or something like
that yes so I feel like maybe they might
not acclimate as well I don't know maybe
they would it depends where you brought
them to earlier on earlier on in the
show we got we were [ __ ] [ __ ] with
each other about scientists and what
scientists think don't Elevate
scientists they're just regular people I
[ __ ] lived in Somerville
Massachusetts and would go down to
[ __ ] Harvard and [ __ ] MIT all the
time and hang out with the clubs the
people that went to MIT yeah some of
them are smart a lot of them are smart
they're just people though you know what
I mean and they have no one ever said
they were they have all as science is
nothing more than a tool to try to find
truth but there's a lot of problems with
[ __ ] truth
um truth has a lot to do with [ __ ]
how you want to see things and you can
[ __ ] [ __ ] data up and and screw
things up to make any reality
science and science is real close to
philosophy
and philosophy is [ __ ] up too
so at an early age I was skeptical of
people [ __ ] they called themselves
scientists [ __ ] they were coming out
of MIT we were in the same clubs with
them
and uh they're dumb yeah duh uh dumb
[ __ ] couldn't get laid new
nerds yeah they could crunch numbers and
they can come up with some [ __ ] but I
just never really saw that as anything
yeah there is truth there is scientific
truth
but a lot of times [ __ ] corruption is
involved with that so are you sure that
you're not just bad because they were
smarter than you they're not that smart
they weren't as smart as you think they
are I'll take you down there if you want
DJ Maniac says Bram Strikers Bram
Strokers fuckula yeah yeah thank you
that was like it was right there I can't
believe I didn't get that I can't
believe I didn't get that yeah
I can't believe I didn't get that I mean
I was trying to like think of like some
more I don't know I was like trying to
think of some more like [ __ ] flowery
sort of titles and it's like but fuckily
was right there I don't know I didn't
get that
smart to me is hard sciences and people
that could actually make machines that
work to me that's smart but like I said
in your opinion a lot of only one that
matters a lot of them well I'm just
saying because they can make things that
actually can prove themselves because
they work uh but there's a lot of people
yeah [ __ ] it never mind Jenny Jenny's
locked into a into a theological concept
uh no that's not what it is people
people are people the IQ is the [ __ ]
reality but IQ Zach says we should do a
show on Henry VII okay I agree we
probably should I don't know why we
haven't done one by now but okay
I'm writing it down right now see yeah
Mr 88 says I think many scientists would
be irritated with how much has been
discovered that we absolutely know but
is denied because of some exterior
reason I agree you know
but you know we're not going to get into
that because
Tom knows everything man listen to her
that's not what I said Tom knows
everything science is constantly or what
what is true is constantly changing the
science of today will be erased by the
science of tomorrow
all right but that's well not necessary
it's not erased it's built upon it's the
same thing and sometimes no it's not the
same thing it's not the same thing you
don't completely erase things you don't
abandon things you're like look they
discovered this and it's like for a
while that worked and that was fine yeah
well no that's not it's like it turned
out it was maybe like partially true but
it's like they didn't know this about it
so then we built upon that so it's all
like building upon stuff it's not that
we just like oh we're completely
starting over from scratch because
you're not right you're building upon
stuff I think it's corrupt all right
there's a lot of corruption and money
and sex involved if you [ __ ] pay a
scientist he'll say anything if you
[ __ ] get him to [ __ ] some underage
girls and get him on video he'll say
anything
you just will
they're weak men all right I've seen
them in action they can't get laid in a
club
they just can't so you could you got to
get him from the gangster way and
because the average person believes in
what they say you can use them as
puppets
to further your ability to gain riches
you're making money gaining power
but you can absolutely believe whatever
Alex Jones says or whatever you think
about [ __ ] is on there no no of course
not some [ __ ] on YouTube says
something you can believe that of course
not you can believe that of course not I
don't believe that sure you do no you do
though no yeah you do where are you
getting this because that's all you do
is
I believe that there's a [ __ ] world
economic Forum because of he watches
YouTube all day long I don't watch we I
don't watch dogs all day long but well
you know you listen to Alex Jones all
night though on your head there's an
entire jar of all the things so where he
got right over time he's a crazy man
which are this big no it's big there is
a [ __ ] jar filled with [ __ ] that he
was right about he's a crazy
[ __ ] I think he's hilarious all
right but I think a lot of okay look I
listen to a lot of scientific programs
they have [ __ ] a lot of scientists on
there and they're right about a lot of
[ __ ] but it's mostly about hard Sciences
about talking cosmology Stars uh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that you can actually prove social
sciences and [ __ ] some Earth yeah but
nobody's talking about that no of course
well earth science is physical science
yeah but you can find social science and
psychology that's another thing that's
well they call that sun that's what I'm
talking about what the [ __ ] science do
you think I'm talking about
why are we talking about social sciences
and [ __ ] like that no you weren't
talking about that but the thing is is
that earth science is [ __ ] weak no of
course it's not though no there's been
no changes it's not it's been very not
enough changes
yeah well okay you can think whatever
you want carbon dioxide you're not right
but carbon dioxide is not always carbon
okay
neither are you carbon dioxide poisonous
and yet you're lecturing me as though
you know more than I do and you don't
and you actually I don't care that's
what I'm saying that's the thing I don't
care but carbon dioxide is not poisonous
you don't care you just believe what you
want to believe how much is not
poisonous and he'll just look and see
the coastlines haven't changed
how do you know that because they have
it
how do you know that because everything
that the [ __ ] okay Plymouth Rock's
still there all the buildings yeah it's
not it hasn't been that long so do you
understand like I have to be that long
do you understand how human timelines
work as opposed to geological timelines
or no yeah do you not understand that
yeah but evidently you don't understand
it yeah but you don't care because
there's been no changes because you
already think you know everything I
don't think there's been any changes
yeah but you're not you're wrong but you
don't obviously don't care about that so
he doesn't care that he's wrong no you
don't care that you're wrong
people will just move if the coastlines
change people will just move uh they
have like they always have been you know
that right they always have been of
course okay no big deal of course
Tom doesn't care about anything and Tom
thinks he knows everything you're
talking about tens of thousands of years
or hundreds of thousands of years no
you're not yeah no you're not of course
you are no you're not of course you are
no you're not just telling you
okay it won't matter he knows more than
I do that's you know I just see what's
real no you don't you really don't but
okay how would you know
how would you know could I know because
[ __ ] I know because I watched some
YouTube videos no is what's talking what
would be better to go to a university
how would that be better
why is it better to watch random I just
[ __ ] on YouTube I just look at
those people and I go oh no I would
never believe that [ __ ] I just
look at them and go no no no no no
I know a loser when I see one you are
kind of yeah yeah I just look at you
you're kind of an idiot yeah
I just look at them and go oh [ __ ] no I
would never believe that dude
you know I know a loser when I see one
they just do
yeah when I see a little [ __ ]
like that no [ __ ] no never
I've never believe a dude like that so
Tom says someone who looks like a loser
they are exactly as they appear can't be
right about it they are exactly as they
appear please stop yelling I'm just
telling no I'm just having fun they are
exactly that's not fun you're you're
being okay really you're trying to be
out loud okay you're trying to be
high-minded about it no you're gonna be
fool yourself that way they are exactly
as they appear exactly
yeah okay they are yep that's how people
are
Tom knows everything yes the end I know
people I know people very well no you
don't yes I do
you absolutely don't but okay I do okay
yeah I can just look at him and go oh I
know what I'm dealing with there yeah
yeah again Tom knows everything the end
all right so I don't know everything I
just know people
I know a liar when I see one I know a
weak person when I see one I know a
strong person when I see one I know a
person that I can break
and [ __ ] I know when a motherfucker's
just going through the motions obeying
what they were told
to believe in you know I just know I can
just tell
it's Instinct it's Instinct and it's
okay people are what they look like too
okay
they're not some kind of elevated thing
and the thing is is [ __ ] she thinks
I'm anti-science no there are scientists
that I [ __ ] love but there's a lot of
them that I got now that motherfucker's
full of [ __ ]
you know I could tell I could tell the
difference
I just can't like I love it Avi Loeb I
love that dude I think that's a real
scientist
because he's breaking the mold
he's telling people that no there are
aliens out there
there has to be well no one's arguing
about that no I mean everybody can in
his world they are in his the world that
he came from they're saying oh no no no
no no
no well it just in the sense that well
what proof do we have no I get that you
know but it's just kind of you don't uh
you kind of do you don't you kind of you
don't need proof that there's aliens
it's fun you just have to feel it in
your gut if that's how it works it's
common sense
it's common sense that there's aliens
the numbers tell you that
and then [ __ ] you look at Earth and
you go this isn't a [ __ ] rare
situation where Earth is this is common
you know I mean there's lots of these so
of course when you're dealing with
numbers this big the life's everywhere I
think life is common
I think well I do too but the thing
about it is that
life being common in the universe and
hush okay life being common in the
universe and life having visited Earth
are two completely different things
um two completely different if it's
common and you're dealing with deep time
then chances are that it comes here
maybe but like I said you know unless
you have some real hard evidence of that
like you know maybe they've been here I
wouldn't be like my mind wouldn't be
blown or anything like that it's like oh
yeah there they are I'm not you know
like I said I find alien stuff like UFOs
and stuff like that boring and I think a
lot of it's fake but
you know I like I said there's probably
aliens out there someplace like I said
the [ __ ] I think there's lots like I
said that's not crazy but whether
they've actually come here and like
probed people and all that kind of stuff
well I'm just using that I'm using that
as an example of like people that have
seen like UFOs and stuff like that I
think a lot of that sighting the
sightings are because I think like just
because there are aliens in the universe
which I there probably are I mean
statistically it's probably likely
have they come here have they you know
shown themselves to us that's another
question that one I'm pretty still
pretty doubtful about
um yeah there have been some compelling
stuff about it but it's like show me
something really
compelling you know what I mean and I'm
not saying they're not out there they
probably are
have they been here
I don't know I think automatically but
like I said that's not that's not crazy
to me that's not like a crazy Fringe
kind of thing that's mostly what I'm
talking about when when you [ __ ] talk
about science they're actually gonna poo
poo [ __ ] that is most well because
there's not any evidence that you know
you've been here but like I said them
being out there I don't think you're
gonna find many scientists are like yeah
they're probably out there someplace
all right you can go out and murder a
person and not leave any evidence that
you did it other than the fact that
[ __ ] there's a dead body
evidence really doesn't mean much that's
a human concept I'm just saying the
likelihood
if you stay at home you will never see a
bear but if you go out into the woods
you'll eventually see a bear
they're out there
all right you'll see living creatures
and bugs and [ __ ]
telling you
the universe is filled with life because
I don't think it's right yeah nobody
said it wasn't I don't think it's rare
nobody else I think there's a lot of
[ __ ] I think there's a lot of species
that travel in between Stars
maybe they do like I said that's not
crazy and here's the deal if that's the
trial if that's a reality which I think
it is then that means they're very old
that their some of them are very old so
I think probably I think probably what
the situation is is that there are
several in this galaxy several
civilizations that know about Earth and
the fact that it has life on it
and they've known about it for thousands
of years and we're just a number in one
of their damn catalogs and they know
about us so maybe they send a probe and
maybe some probes come by every now and
then but they don't really care this
isn't really a big deal because I think
that this is probably common
but see this is why I think that science
will back up because science will say
yeah statistically it's probably very
likely that there's life on other
planets or in other galaxies but if
that's true why the [ __ ] would they come
here
why the [ __ ] would they come here
I wouldn't come here if I was that it
would be one of many thousands that's
what I'm saying so it's just kind of
like all of these that's what I'm saying
that's why I don't buy like a lot of
these kind of like people that are like
oh this UFO and that UFO and like we saw
this and that I don't buy any of that
crap because
why the [ __ ] would they come here I'm
not saying they don't exist I'm just
saying why the [ __ ] would they come here
there have been many they don't have any
reason to there have been many good many
reputable accounts from [ __ ] military
Pilots that have been confirmed by radar
that there were strange things and I
would I would think that they would be
AI probes
just probes
that have [ __ ] you know flown around
clear day dude said this is what happens
when Tom does not get one of his wigs
yeah man you wait we want to put a
[ __ ] wig up man [ __ ] y'all people
I mean it would have been more fun if
you'd have a big one
why don't you do your wigs anymore
actually and it's just kind of like
you're not like what are you talking
about you've been doing that most of the
show not at all and then like you don't
like put your fun not at all you know
like I said Friday night's supposed to
be fun man and you're making it like
you're making it like not fun I'm not
I'm having fun
well of course you are yeah it's almost
time because you get to yell at me and
like tell me tell me I'm stupid and
wrong
this is how it is
happening put your bald ass head I'm
just bald ass head I'm not saying you're
stupid I'm just I'm just I'm not saying
you're stupid I'm just saying I know
I'm just saying no I'm not saying yeah
that's exactly what you're saying it's
not these [ __ ] that's exactly I'm not
saying you're stupid just saying that
I'm just saying that
you're you're you're blowing over a
bunch of stuff you're taking certain
things you're taking certain things for
granted am I though yeah I think you are
I don't I don't believe them I don't
[ __ ] believe them well I don't
believe I don't respect them I don't
believe you you know I was I hung out
with him you just yell and you just
yelling and you listen to a bunch of
YouTube channels where everybody yells
everybody's yelling listen this [ __ ]
I [ __ ] hung out with those [ __ ]
when I was up and [ __ ]
I met a scientist once and I don't like
that dude so I don't trust any
scientists I met five scientists and I
don't like them because they were losers
who couldn't get laid so I don't believe
anything they say they're just like now
30 years later they're just more college
that dude what you said they're just
more broke college that's what you said
you can get them to say anything that's
what you said you can get them to say
anything I mean I kind of feel like you
just want people to believe what you
like already believe you just don't want
I don't care you do though no you do
keep saying don't believe them because
no why should anyone believe you though
why should anyone believe you though I
wouldn't believe them I wouldn't believe
you either you could [ __ ] just pay
them anything
why should anyone believe you though
I don't care if they do
you don't have any reason for that you
don't have any evidence behind it why
would I why now I'm just no people I
know people real well and I just he
knows I'm gonna be like man don't listen
to those dudes
science so anyway oh they'll [ __ ]
pull all this science [ __ ] out but
they're just [ __ ] dudes that [ __ ]
jerk exactly it's time you're in trouble
tonight he is I ain't worried about that
Zach [ __ ] you Zach he doesn't care Zach
was here to just suck dick
suck some dick Zack come over here Zach
you need to hit me up because [ __ ] oh
never mind he needs somebody to suck his
dick give him a suck my dick
he wants a boy to do it he won't admit
it I I know I know y'all are [ __ ]
real good at sucking dick
look she's trying to get she's trying to
get me to [ __ ] act up in front I told
her I mean her than you she's trying to
get me to act up in front of the [ __ ]
camera I don't worry about this [ __ ] I
tell you look what time is it it is 9
44. okay it's almost time to get off
[ __ ] Channel I gotta make us
something to eat aren't you hungry
not really but yeah oh well a little bit
I'm [ __ ] hungry
Zach says time keep talking and Jenny's
not gonna break out the strap-on tonight
man I never get to do the strap-on Jenny
didn't have a strap he's no fun Jenny
doesn't even he won't even let me get us
this is she didn't have a [ __ ]
strap-on [ __ ] all this [ __ ] he won't
let me do the pegging the [ __ ]
all you hoes try to gang up on a
[ __ ] oh man I've been drinking
since today
whose fault is that y'all couldn't even
be [ __ ] standing
after after the amount of alcohol I
drank
you couldn't even be standing no
no we couldn't even be talking either
and you're not talking you're just
yelling
Mr 88 said if she's trying to get you to
act up she's succeeding yeah yeah she is
I mean it's very easy I mean it's easy
to get him to act up I bet we're here
[ __ ] over 10 years this is how she
does it's very easy to get him to act up
I ain't worried about it he has he has
uh triggers he's very easily I'm not
worried about this [ __ ] he's trying to
[ __ ] with me
uh Zach says also I've never had any
complaints Blair today
[Laughter]
Zach let me tell you something
you were on this show tonight and that
[ __ ] right there fell over
and nobody said anything about it and I
don't know you said something about it I
don't understand how that [ __ ] fell over
why you like you why are you
poltergeisting my [ __ ] over quit
breaking my [ __ ] I don't know how that
felt you already made my like [ __ ]
poster fall off the wall and I had to
put another screw in the wall how to do
that [ __ ] Darth Vader [ __ ] where I
[ __ ] choke your ass without even
touching you on [ __ ] camera then what
would happen
like see this is what I keep worrying
about you're gonna like throw a brick in
my head or some [ __ ] like that nah it
ain't gonna hurt you
it's not gonna hurt you Zack I will kick
your ass [ __ ] I need to get
these women under control
where's yeah you got Poltergeist Powers
but I got like suppressed rage Powers
yeah we'll see how that goes
Mr 88 says I've been drinking since an
hour from now
literally dude said when is The Listener
story submission show happening holy
[ __ ] we haven't done one of those in a
long time do you remember that we did
that [ __ ] it lasted four hours and Jay's
like I can't tell this [ __ ] store
anymore I [ __ ] remember that [ __ ]
well after a time I was like drinking I
was just like and then I had to read and
I was just like oh my God every [ __ ]
book everything's like Blurry well I
think that I didn't have time to like
read everybody's story prior because I
you know
I had a lot of other stuff going on so I
was like yeah everybody's sending the
stories I'm like okay cool and I just
like put them all I compiled them all
I'm gonna read these for the show and
then I was like oh my God this one's so
long and then I was like oh my God I
can't read this anymore but yeah we
should probably do maybe we should do
that for Halloween I feel like we did
Halloween we did that last time that
[ __ ] lasted for six hours seven eight
hours well okay what I'll do this summer
I'll have some parameters like if you're
gonna send some [ __ ] you can't be long
like yeah let's not have it be like
[ __ ] two hours long like don't send
me a novel for phrase sake
um my voice will give out right but if
you have like a short
anecdote or story or something like that
I don't know maybe like we'll think
about it like don't do it right now but
I don't know maybe we'll do that for the
Halloween show this year
what day is Halloween on this year
anybody know I don't know Halloween's
always the same day every year isn't it
it's the same day every year but it's
not the same day of the week every year
no I don't know obviously so it's just
kind of like I don't know if it's on a
weekday or a weekend so I don't really
know if it's gonna fall into Showtime so
we'll see
I don't know we'll see uh
get Shana on
shawna's long gone
we saw her the other day sorry the other
day she's being a [ __ ] she's not you
made her mad because you did something
that I don't know it didn't really
happen she's well I don't know what it
was because she said well you were drunk
and I wasn't there so I don't know if
you did something that like offended her
no because she I don't know it made her
really mad because she's not talking to
you and she's not talking to me no so we
didn't make her mad I don't know what
you did
I wasn't there
I wasn't there so I don't know what
happened I don't know she's making that
up although you were drunk you might
have just done something you didn't
remember no yeah maybe maybe okay maybe
[ __ ] Shawna Zach says uh yes it was my
erotic Powers making the walls quiver
like many gentlemen's loins and my no my
time
connoisseur making the walls quiver like
the walls of that rectum just [ __ ]
like that make it like that Danny
Rowling said uh Halloween's a Monday ah
Monday
um
I don't know maybe we could do like a
special we could do like a matinee show
but like a Halloween matinee show but
that's a haunting day
yeah from now on
I don't know so maybe we'll do like a
special I don't know we'll see
[ __ ] Monday God damn it that sucks
all right well
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do all right so it's almost like 10
o'clock
you're gonna go in like four hours yeah
we want some to eat
I get well what do you got I don't know
I'll find I'll find us a snack or
something
because I'm not that hungry you're not
that hungry okay but just like something
small would be it I can do that
something small veggie based okay not
okay I got more Baba ganoushatter I mean
that's that would be good that'd be good
that'd be fine all right all right so
we'll be back on Sunday I think probably
we'll be talking about the Gwar
documentary because that's all we've
watched lately and we probably won't
watch anything tonight and I don't know
if we're going out tomorrow night so we
might not be able to watch anything
tomorrow night so oh [ __ ] that's kind of
awesome was in there asking about it
yeah yeah yeah okay
and you are all mean I didn't know that
it was oh [ __ ] I don't like I don't even
know what happened thank you Jeffy Art
thank you just got back from work hey oh
my God it's been like four hours just so
much good uh you mentioned running out
of Christmas material maybe do the
submissions show then yeah that might be
a good thing to do I don't know I mean
there's still like some Christmas horror
movies out there we could cover but
get some shrimp and peas Jenny
Jeffrey Hart says sorry work that's okay
I mean we've been on for four hours we
got into like two fights
it's a like not physical place
they weren't fights we just saw
what's that thing they love this [ __ ]
everybody likes that [ __ ] yeah
even though I'm just kind of like Jesus
Christ can we please just have like a
good time it's just kind of like no when
you go to like Thanksgiving dinner and
you have that one uncle that nobody
wants to like look at her dude that just
like yaps about like politics and
religion the whole time and just like oh
my God I wish this dude didn't shut up
so I could like [ __ ] just eat some
turkey and peace don't listen there it's
like that
but it's like so it's not a physical
fight but it's like it's not an NPC
about the [ __ ] you know what I mean
[ __ ] I I have my own question oh my
God why are you using that terminology
I'm just because that's how I'm going
that's how I'm coming I don't [ __ ]
believe what they tell me I'm very
defiant and uh you're not though it's
like the only per the only people that
use that terminology are people that are
like in this little weird like right alt
right bubble nobody uses that
terminology other than that I do what I
want to do I'm just saying it and it
seems so to us it seems like you're just
parroting like the same terms because
everybody's using the same time your
parody so I I don't care I don't care Mr
88 said that one Uncle dead on yeah we
all have that one well I have more than
one but you know I don't I know what
you're talking about her whole family
would agree with me okay no they
wouldn't but yeah they would no they
wouldn't you don't know my family
how many times have you met my family
you've met my family like one time
no they wouldn't
I don't care what you I don't care what
you think yeah I know I just do what I
want to do and I hate her I do what I
want I do what I buy like a toddler yeah
like a toddler does with it I'll just do
what I want I don't give a [ __ ] I do
what I want he doesn't give a [ __ ] uh
Sarah says Tom working Jenny up till she
finally tells him to shut it is the best
partnership sorry about that I am not
worried about this I don't care I don't
care I'm just doing what I want well if
you didn't care you wouldn't go on so
much about it no it's all fun and games
I think it's just you're protesting too
much like Shakespeare said all right I
don't care I don't care I don't care I'm
going I don't care I'm going I don't
give a [ __ ] it's the anavar I'm going no
he was like that before nah it was like
before that just made it worse yeah and
I'm not on it no I'm not on it that just
made it worse it's as far as girls it's
just Amplified it's just one of our girl
steroids
[ __ ] I don't want those girls steroids
girl steroids
oh my God nobody wants to be like girl
girls are the worst no I was just saying
that's girl steroids ooh girls aren't
allowed at a clubhouse that doesn't do
anything to me
people ask you if I'm going to
mannequins I mean you know not tonight
no I mean we might get a Barbarella
tomorrow yeah
I kind of like I wanna
I wanna get a Barbarella on a Saturday
okay because last time we went to
Barbarella on Saturday that was like
super fun
although we got there really late
because we've been we we got there super
late oh [ __ ] it was Ryan okay we're
going oh my God I haven't seen him in
forever yeah the the bar no the
bartender from football Oh I thought you
meant like Ryan I think we're going to
we may be going to [ __ ] barbarella's
uh
Saturday right yeah
yeah I thought you meant other Ryan no
we're talking about the um
the doorman
oh okay oh I didn't know his name was
Ryan too yeah okay I thought you meant
other Ryan we know we know like three
people named Ryan
I didn't know which one was going on
yeah tell me I mean you know you're
making America but the thing about it is
like we hadn't been to Barbarella
because like I said I talked about like
the new location which I'm I was
ambivalent about but I'm kind of like
warming up to it you're trying to get
get us to go out tonight
God damn it it's already like 10 o'clock
yeah I don't have time for that nonsense
okay you know what I mean yeah I would
rather have
a day like to relax and get ready y'all
got her [ __ ] wired up see you gotta
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm always wired up okay
what are you talking about they didn't
get me wired up okay
Jeffy our kid that was a long time ago
okay I already brought that up all right
did you miss it or I'm going okay bye
see she keeps [ __ ] with me so I gotta
go because barbarella's having orgasm
down wait shut that [ __ ] down it doesn't
but it should oh you know what we should
bring that up because
if he wants to get into the whole
experience I mean okay so the thing
about it back in the old days I mean
because the [ __ ] was open it used to be
in downtown Orlando and it was called
Barbarella
obviously named after the movie
but uh yeah so they didn't really lean
into the theme all that much so it's
been in downtown Orlando for like
forever and then recently they moved to
another like a warehousey location
and they're not like leaning into the
theme as much they were called
independent Bar for a very long time
which is what I always still call it
because that's kind of what I knew it as
so they went back to the old name though
and maybe they should like lean more
into that make it more like a Barbarella
like the movie they should have an
orgasmatron they should have like the
whole 60s kind of vibe but like it's you
know they do like it's an alternative
Club but they do like 80s stuff mostly
it's like 80s new wave and then they do
like goth industrial kind of night too
but I don't know we might go tomorrow
night we'll see how it goes if I'm not
still mad at him I still want to shut
that [ __ ] down t-shirt
you know I should probably make that you
should probably make that I forgot but I
admitted the many other things shot that
[ __ ] down I'll make one
eventually I don't know how long it'll
take but I will get around to it
uh I'm gonna watch Legend and the
Werewolf is The Vampire Woman okay you
have fun with that wait Legend the one
with like Tom Cruise and bears Mia Sarah
and Tim Curry because that's a good one
although it wasn't like other than the
stuff with
you know the devil
and all of that
I don't know I I kind of feel like Tom
Cruise is a little bit miscast in that
but other than that I really liked it
but that's awesome all right so we will
see you guys on Sunday probably be
talking about the Gwar documentary it's
just called this is bar if you have a
shutter you can watch it it's like I
said it's two and a half hours long but
it flew by it was like I thought it was
like fascinating if you're into Gwar I
mean if you're not it'd probably be like
really boring but you know what I mean
uh so yeah it was fun so we'll probably
be talking about that on Sunday and
hopefully you guys have a good weekend
up until then and we'll see you guys
again on Sunday evening thanks for
dropping by thanks for all your super
chats and we'll see you guys later bye